welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
[Applause]
you do it for the men but it's like
sexual tension it's not relationship
attention so you can kind of do a cheat
code you can go get a BBL get a nice
body and you do get more attention from
them than if you're flat right but
here's the thing though no no but but
listen though but it goes so deeper
though because I know what you're
talking about and she has a great body
yeah so you got to think about how far
down deep that she is within watching
the Instagram models within watching The
Cosmopolitan magazines
doesn't look good to a man wait you
think that men have higher standards for
women not that the men have the higher
standards they have to live up to just
to clarify I think men have highest
unders for women for women so like the
women have higher beauty standards to me
yes and that's what's making women feel
like they need to comply with these
standards who's pickier men or women men
women are more complacent than them
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept more than men do you think men
are very like if they're they've got a
certain standard they're more rigid than
women I think men are pickier than women
100 certainly but they will not marry it
they will not settle down with somebody
with a fake or lips the eyebrows and if
they do it ain't gonna last oh I I don't
know any fans but it wasn't like vagina
boobs it was lingerie yeah builds right
whatever I'd done it and when I finished
it I felt very degraded I felt very like
why did I actually do that now I know
there's girls out there who do that they
don't feel that way that is perfectly
fine you do you you feel the way you
feel but me personally like like in the
future how like when I have kids and all
in the future and if my kids found out
about that they'll probably get bullied
in school there are people like oh your
mom doing this your mom doing that and
your man as well he's not coming if you
don't respect yourself and you're
selling your body online I can't speak
for everyone I can just speak for myself
if you're selling your body online like
that there's not there's not high
respect for yourself
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos a couple
announcements before we start the show
the first guys is send some super chats
blessing what are what are you trying to
save for today God only knows with you
people come yeah blessing wants a kick
out cam so
um if you want you know a 360 shot of
the room when people get kicked out
which isn't gonna happen today right
guys yeah okay so send super chats and
we are going to be saving for that also
guys and we're adding Tuesday to our
live show schedule so we had a live show
Tuesday and it's the schedule moving
forward is gonna be Tuesday Thursdays
and Saturdays also guys um make sure you
like the video that's the most important
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these live streams and leave a
comment with your thoughts uh blessing
how many likes to open up the chat today
a thousand likes and we will open up the
chat today uh for now it is members only
though so make sure you sign up for our
first membership tier a like is free
guys so like the video come on second
tier you get to be a part of our Discord
and our behind the scenes Vlogs if you
want to see me freestyle rapping um sign
up for the second tier that's in our
behind the scenes Vlogs also guys third
tier you get to connect with me on
social media and fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month
do you want to know how to get a million
subscribers in a year I'm sign up for
that tier also guys go follow my
Instagram they banned my first one um so
it's just pearly things one they also
ban five of my Tick Tock accounts I know
five in this crazy five it's like five
five anyways so go follow my new one
just pearly thanks also guys make sure
you go subscribe to wife school and we
have a new episode out right now with
Maggie the substitute teacher she was a
guest on our show a couple weeks back
where she went through what I would cook
for a family of four in a day
um also guys
um make sure you go subscribe to our
three uh mem or three talents channels
now we have amiri's Channel um Auntie
Jenny and King riches so make sure you
go subscribe to all three of them um the
link should be in the description okay
so hi guys welcome to the show um to
start um everyone say your name your age
um your relationship status a fun fact
about yourself and where you're from
starting here and then go around yeah
sure so I'm Vicky I am 30 and I'm dating
someone at the moment I fun fact I'm
half Indian and half Italian what was
the last question
um where you're from
um I live in North London
go ahead oh so yeah
um my name's LV General
um I'm a YouTuber or you could say I'm
Entertainer because I do a bit of
everything also music as well um I'm 35.
um my relationship situation I'll put a
question mark on Cardinal you don't want
to know so yeah and no I do want to know
that's why I asked the question yeah I
know I know you want to know that's what
I'm saying is it I've got a question
mark I'll chat to you after about it
you'll chat to me after oh okay yeah
it's like a situation yeah it's one of
those ones if I say you're here to talk
about it's going to be everywhere we're
here to talk about relationships we'll
keep them waiting let them work me out
let them work me out
right yeah and I'm from lewisham yeah
blue Borough
where's that
um
not far from it
I've been in England too long tonight
I'm okay go ahead my name is Alicia I'm
21 and I'm in a relationship and I can't
think of a fun fact off of my head do
you have any hobbies
um I have a dog that's my fun fact yeah
yeah and where are you from South East
London okay cool yeah yeah I'm Pushkin
I'm a musician I'm from North London
Wood Green
um relationship status is
um exploring I'm having fun okay so
isn't that single I just I don't
understand we I always get these like
weird answers like you know dating
having fun and when it's just like are
you single are you not single you know
well having fun all right
okay um go ahead hi my name is Oz I'm
from South West London I'm 28. um I'm
Into Fitness college and then training
people getting the best shape possible
uh fun fact
um
I like to boss jokes I'll say
okay
well thank you guys for coming so today
we're going to talk about you know the
modern dating market so uh my first
question is what is a big turn off for
you when you're starting to see someone
is that no it's not me there's someone
over there when you're starting to see
someone and something they could do to
just ruin it up front
um yeah you can start like around I
would say being like disrespectful
probably in any kind of way I mean just
I just don't like disrespect I think
that's it's a big thing for me for a man
like a guy to be a gentleman and to be
respectful so I would say that for me
that's a big turn off okay and do you
have like an example of a time that's
happened where where you were into a guy
and then he said something he just um I
suppose it may be like the way it got
some the way that a guy's spoken to me
before it's more like the tone or um
yeah I guess don't really don't have an
exact example but I think just any kind
of disrespect I don't really like okay
okay
um go ahead
um say the question again please so
what's what's it something a girl could
do to turn you off early so you're into
a girl you're feeling her and then
she does this and it's you're done it
depends though I'm not fussy okay I
don't think I'm a fussy one carb not but
it depends car I could go out with her
and she might eat loud hey so I can't
stand that that's annoying do you get me
oh she could just do something what's
irritating but I don't know it there's a
number of things will irritate people
like me in it so okay yeah but I'm
trying to figure it out so what are they
that's what I'm saying I would have to
just throw it if because you're telling
me to toe off the top of the Dome it's
gonna have to I'm just gonna go with the
eating loud thing that I've been on a
date before in the past where I've done
sat down got starters everything if it
was going fine talking flowing well
conversations moving nice yeah and all
of a sudden I've started my meals come
play stare boom drink whatever I've just
heard beer and it was just constantly
hearing that and that's it that's a yeah
no that's a flag for me still okay I
think that's a fair that's a fair flag
yeah yeah
I would say I would agree and say the
um uh respect thing but I'd also say the
pet pee thing as well it's a mixture of
both
if someone's like you said eating loud
or every time you're talking they're
cutting you off or
they got the White Corners it could be
anything it could really be anything it
just adds up yeah do you have an example
of maybe how long have you been with
your boyfriend cheers oh gosh yeah so
you don't really have much experience
that's great that's longer than like
most marriages nowadays too thank you
um okay so eating loud
um and disrespect is a no-go for you I'm
curious what made your boyfriend I'm
different than I'm sure there was other
guys approaching you at the time I met
him when I was young so it was in school
so that was like the main
point of it all that he wasn't new to my
school so everyone in my um
in my secondary school were kind of like
really similar and of course he come
from a different area he was quite
different to everyone you treat me
different how everyone else did so yeah
okay
um pet peeve or something that a girl
could do to turn you off
I'm really easy again but hygiene would
be a big factor for me
um yeah personal hygiene is going to be
a big issue if that's not gonna if
that's not straight
okay have you ever been like with a girl
and then she just stank so you gotta
um yeah except for the girl before on
the hygiene
weren't up to speed okay and is that
common
um no no no I'm actually sure it's a
one-off like oh yeah yeah it was yeah
yeah it wasn't good okay okay
go ahead yeah I'll say pettiness and
I'll say clinginess as well both I think
clingy's more extremely clingy that way
too soon
um can I have an example yeah for
instance like if you're on what's
Happening like you're online but you're
not even responded you know I'm saying
to you straight away and it's just like
oh you're blanking me you're hearing me
you know I'm saying oh if you get mad
yeah create a whole situation from that
that's kind of petty stuff like that
that's kind of crazy because you're just
sitting there looking if you're online
no just like maybe she's online I'm
online at the same time and it's like
they're both online and it's like maybe
she meshes me and I haven't measured her
straight away or I'm online and then
it's just assumptions that oh yeah you
know why have you mentioned me what are
you doing I mean I'm curious from the
girls have you ever done that to a guy
like get mad at him for not messaging
you fast enough no no it's not really my
style at all
um
yeah I feel like I'm really busy as well
and I just wouldn't do that I feel like
it's kind of like a bit cringy to do
that and it seems like desperate it's
just it's not and also I feel like it
also probably pushes the guy away
because he needs to to come to you
naturally
what do you guys think the biggest
challenges are in dating in 2023
being faithful
that's a challenge
yeah why
okay
I don't even know he's gonna do that
sorry if I put man under the bus no no
I'm just thinking about it because yeah
I'm gonna display anything well yeah I
think being faithful is the biggest
challenge in relationships into an in
this day and age do you mean to find
someone that's faithful you mean well
when you're already in a relationship
being faithful is going to be the
biggest challenge both of you are second
both of you or
um yeah I think
I mean maybe not so much
oh yeah yeah both parties women and men
that's pretty much the same
you think it's equal I think women cheat
more I think so as well yeah I I think
women are big cheaters
for women then yeah that's good it's
good to hear for us okay I would have
said 50 51 yeah
you know you gotta be up we're honest
I'm loving that I'm loving the fact
you're honest yeah I mean before it used
to definitely I would have brought up
way around men cheating more now I
thought was kind of evened up but then
use it uh I think most people I think
most men would cheat but not most men
can cheat you know what I mean like it
seems like it's a lot of effort to get
to that point for a lot of guys from
what I'm hearing you know you can
correct me if you think I'm wrong no I
again it depends what kind of guy you um
what status the position you're in I
would say so everyone's going to talk
about their own personal experience so
why have you cheated before I have
definitely yeah is it is that like in
every relationship kind of thing or just
a here and there kind of thing
um what are side chicks like
[Laughter]
are they happy to be there are they
always trying to like Vie for the first
spot I just got questions
good question I mean I think they're
happy to be there you know in my in the
left my younger days cheating with more
of a cheating thing nowadays I don't see
as cheating if you're honest and open
and it's and I can set you at the
beginning I'm exploring I'm the incent
having fun so if people know you're
having fun from the beginning then
you're not necessarily going to be
deemed as cheating laughing forever I
think that is a hard place to get to in
today's the incense yeah nowadays so now
you tell the girls up front it's not
it's not you if there's going to be
multiple and they're cool with it
yes I know that I mean again it all
depends it's variables it's variables
but yeah he's laughing what's that
what's the joke I'm not in on it why are
you putting the camera on me for a
little bit to do that
to do that no I hear what my man's
saying isn't it big up bushkin in that
air what you're saying but you see where
it is blood in my eyes yeah
and everyone's cheated in their life
come on we've all been there do you
understand but as time's gone on I think
2023 if you're not grown I think the
youngest them are more likely the ones
to keep up this type of [__] you
understand what cheating the cheating
thing yeah it's the new generation but
that's having too much fun they're out
there whipping all that in anything Gala
digging up anything this girl [__] that
girl [__] your friend this friend yeah
wow sorry it's the younger generation
that's your opinion yeah I'm not going
to take it as the older ones are doing
that you know what but I think it's a
smart it's a small percentage of men
that can do that no there's one one out
of three men under 30 are virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year so it's
really the women that are sleeping
around when you think about it but
that's bad on the women you know I feel
like women do it more they just hide it
better yeah than men what do you mean
what do you mean by hide it better well
I wouldn't know if I've never cheated
from what you've heard from your
favorite what you're hearing yeah how
does that happen and not like women lie
better than men in my opinion women lie
better than men and I feel like well I
can't give you an example because then
I'm going to be hurting up like no no I
just wanted to know yeah
could you tell me I mean because you
you've got this opinion from somewhere I
know it's not you you're a faithful
girlfriend yeah yeah but you you sure
I'm sure in six years right you know
someone that's cheated right yeah okay
so what's so what's the question so like
what happened why did she cheat how did
she cheat I feel like people in my
generation think that they can go find
better quick because they're still young
so uh like you have your variables it
might be they're good looking I know men
like good looking young healthy whatever
it is
we're not in their Prime when they're
young right so
did that make sense no but I was asking
about it you seemed like you said that
women you said women yeah so I'm asking
like do you know someone who cheated
yeah they just go out and do what they
want to do like oh yeah it's not it's
not like I'm asking is it is it like are
they sleeping with random men every
night is it the same guy who knows to
say like a girl could go out say like
she's going out with her friends or
whatever and let's say she's talking to
two people one she's actually been in a
relationship with on and off on an off
weekend she could go out with her friend
and go do something with the second
person wow but in the first person's
head
they think that they're maybe like still
together or whatever
okay so the first person is she in a
relationship so she's on and off she's
on and off with the first person okay
but in that person's head she's there on
does that make sense yeah oh okay so so
really like they both think they're the
only one but there's two
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah kind of
kind of yeah
you know I think I think social media is
the big big difference you know because
I think that everyone's like so glued on
social media trying to like watch what
people are doing so I was like
um people have like unrealistic
expectations they'll compare their life
to someone else's life on social media
and then when you know arguments are
happening like oh you didn't take me out
to cinema or my friend look she's on
Instagram she took me out to whatever
boom boom and it's just like too much
too much watch over people I thought
that makes a big difference as well and
plus ultimate role like all the girls in
that are just uh you're from Young just
showing body image image if it's all you
know this girls but in Germany if it's
all image so I was like everyone's
always showing image image though
everything just seems like very sexual
that's why people just under cheating
thing as well I think
I think social media really affects
women more than it does men are men
really on social media like that yeah of
course all the time like by and large
you think so you think it's equal I
don't know about equal but I feel it
does affect a lot of men's though I feel
a lot of men you know get affected by
you know on social media what they see
in that as well and that makes them that
go crazy like a lot of my friends and
that they'll be like no link um before
they link girls and like they'll be
doing that background research checklist
of you know I mean seeing what they've
done um what they count all this crazy
stuff because seriously yeah because
it's like they think we're all like I
want to know if this goals that how many
that actually seductive they do
background research how do they do that
listen I'll be honest with you
this button account thing's rule it's
burning about creating burner accounts
and this you know messaging people and
doing loads of things it's crazy are you
saying men do that or women do that I
think men do that wait so okay
burner account I know got couple guys
okay what do they do with these I've
just never remember this just great but
no accounts and just like message goals
and see okay that's a potential goal to
see what you know the same testimony
just do testing it to see oh so they
tested yeah to see if they're that they
make like a really attractive burner
account I don't know if it's attractive
I don't know what it's like the
statistical to see if she's like serious
on that all you know what I mean
okay so they'll test like if they want
to chat to a girl they'll test the girl
with another account to see if she yeah
to pretend to be someone else you get
and then they'll they'll make me link in
the girl pretend to be someone else and
then message them and see okay cool okay
that awesome couple questions and see
they can see what they're saying yeah he
said the man the market is small
that just made me my brain tick twice I
said what they're doing Mad accounts so
a man can see so if I'm linking a thing
I'll make a new account yeah sat on what
she's attracted in to like obviously and
then just try and pattern her like that
and see see she's seriously oh yeah I'm
not seeing no one at the moment and then
but then you'll match up your own link
yeah in a way because that's that's her
it seems like a lot of effort yeah it's
a lot of effort
yeah and I was like that sounds like
there must be a feminine Dukes that
sounds like something yeah
it's like detective work that's too much
yeah I just think there's loads of
insecurities don't
and to be fair like I would say like
rightfully rightfully so but that's just
a lot like a lot going on
I agree with what you said earlier I was
just saying a lot of time on the hands
yeah I agree with what you said earlier
when you mentioned the social media has
taken over it has in my time obviously
I'm 35 in it so they weren't no YouTube
there wasn't no Instagram there wasn't
no all that so my way ain't distracted
you see it but the new generation now I
always keep looking at you because yeah
sorry it's fine yeah I mean but yeah the
New Generation
Um obviously it just they got all the
patterns you get me the social media is
there and I like Bush though like back
in the day was there these things for
man to even do music like that you
understand it was it was the setup was
available you understand I think that
social media affects women more than men
because because women find 80 of men
unattractive so it's not like most men
like if you ask women both on dating
apps and and in person and like you say
do you find this guy attractive this guy
attracted they find 80 unattractive and
that's in person too because a lot of
people will say oh that's just social
media no no no no in person so it's only
a small percentage of guys that are even
getting messages from women like that
yeah
on social media to try to like patent a
girl trying to move to go and I feel
like a lot of guys like I feel like when
I was younger like when you're trying to
if you like a girl you approach her do I
need to move to you know putting games
you know what I'm saying to you I feel
now guys have been lazy because it's
like if it solves me so they just try
sliding DMS and that's why they get
blanked you know what I'm saying you
well yeah because like they an average
oh my gosh an overweight woman on Tinder
gets more matches than the top like like
a model level guy I believe that 100
yeah
is picky as women
actually yeah man oh my God good enough
but yeah God man's my bread on dating
apps 50 of the time where women only
swipe right five percent wow yeah that's
that's a big difference
yeah yeah I think dating apps is also a
problem as well with the whole dating
scene nowadays because it's just so easy
to swipe but just and you don't really
think of the people as like real people
when when they are but you get it's it
takes a Hume inside out of it yeah yeah
well I mean it's also like girls in
their 20s usually get
you know like ran through a bit by the
top 20 percent of men and they start to
settle like in their 30s no I'm serious
ly
because when you think about it like
what are people doing in their 20s it's
situations so what are you what are you
doing in a situationship you're like
it's funny because girls will say that
they're not like they need to be a
monogamous relationship but it's like
how many situation chips have you been
in the summer monogamous it's true
yeah how many have you been in how many
have I been zero I'm a virgin yeah
I'm just kidding yeah
um I did not know what to say yeah
I can answer that one
[Music]
if I laughed that one off yeah yeah next
question
and just like flicking Pages you know
I'm special you know
um anyways
so so
um
what is the worst date you guys have
ever been on
oh my God I got quite a few you know
I'll be honest okay give me give me a
couple I've been I might like a date
with one girl one time yeah and then um
he went to Wonderland yeah and then um
she just wasn't even on it like she just
saw all out she was just like moving
along like I wasn't wanting to play no
games nothing like that and then um I
have to be a restaurant in that and it's
just like just you know when the
chemistry is just so dead that there's
nothing there like literally nothing so
I just thought to myself this is dead so
I literally I thought maybe let's end
the date here so um when we ended the
date I was like okay cool I'm gonna go
because like what's the point and then
she just walked off not even though but
no hugging or nothing I was like this is
this is terrible I don't even know why I
went a day in the first place where what
year
give me another oh my god um you got you
got stories huh
another one
um bad one
yeah I went I went on one date one girl
in a restaurant I should just rude to
the weight of proper route because um
they'll take quite long with the food
and the way she'll just disrespecting
the way I was I don't know this ain't it
you know what I mean at least have some
manners okay I get it like the service
is bad but she just was bad mouth in the
way or and you're just like I'll just I
got mad as well like you can't be
talking to people like that you know I'm
saying anything from there one you just
went downhill so yeah that was not a
good one as well so she started yelling
at what she said to the waiter to start
swearing so you're [__] taking too
long without to start swimming yeah
swearing at the way and then I can see
your eyes this is of hand completely I
can't be in this situation no way you
can't be talking to people like that
because it's that bad on me because I'm
like that like I've come with her so
I've got I was like no no way did you
still pay for the dinner I'll be honest
with you when I go on dates I always
paying it I always paying it so uh I
don't if even things like that I just
don't even like to think about it just
creates too much anxiety for me in terms
of like oh this spit they build just an
artist pay I've come organizing it I
know okay if I'm gonna go somewhere I
know roughly what's going to cost I'll
just pay for it yeah what about you
worst date
I'm trying to think of some well I can't
really think of anything never had a bad
date
no it comes to mind no
I've also never had it yeah yeah
you're not a bad man I like how you two
just skipped it you know is that the
birthday no no I'm good
no no and then now me yeah all right
cool yeah a very bad day so I've took a
nice lady out I'm not gonna say named
car there's no point but anyway
um we went for a mill in where was we
um I think we went to what's that
um ah what is it around God
have you not been Stratford yeah yeah so
it's not in Stratford but there's a shot
Wagga mama that's it so we went back on
my way we're in Stratford it was
somewhere else but we went back on Mama
sat down ordered the mill wherever I got
starters boom bam eight nice boom boom
then the the food's done but before the
food was done this is the same date what
I was talking about yeah so I couldn't
stand that noise in it so that was
pissing me off so in the end I've
mastered the out of the blue I don't
know why I've said it but I said can you
eat quietly please
I don't know where it came from but I
just said it not thinking not enough it
ain't gonna feel no way I'm just being
ruining it boom so that's made there be
in a little mood my girl's got herself
up and decided to pick her jacket up put
a coat on and cut out so I thought all
right cool attitude stinks anyway allow
it but this ain't the worst bit so she's
come back in the shop now where man's if
ready paid for Bill trying to cut out
she's gone out for five minutes so I've
finished my food it quit but I'm done
mating sent back her start I didn't care
so boom I've done my thing and then as
I'm leaving the shop now I'm trying to
go this girl's telling me where you're
going
to go there so I'm not driving or
nothing so I'm having to like now get
she wants to drop me back no I'm driving
you back and I said no bunny I'm getting
a cab this girl's teared my new puffer
Magnum puffer jacket
[Applause]
with my stuff
pulled off my blood my jacket I swear my
mom's life she went mad like just held
on to my [__] and pulled it so all that
the newer ones are flimsier I'm sorry
they don't make that's like scary it's
more than scary people yeah I didn't
understand that I was just like why have
you lost your head that much first date
you know first date been on dates you
get me with the girl but it's that this
time around I've said it I've spoke out
see where it is I let it go past me
you're eating lots
you understand so this is this is the
eating date now now I'm [__] I'm gonna
eat a date with you not marrying mums
here in New gold I'm not feeling it so
obviously me trying to leave I'm just
being the man I am just cut out I ain't
got time for not screaming and shouting
in my ears oh cop you understand so I'm
trying to move I'm like I bought my cab
I'm bouncing no you're not you're
getting my car get in your car for what
I don't need you to drop me home I'm
good like we've had the I've seen your
your attitude how it moves like you get
up and Wanna Hold Cat stool mat and that
dominant come back to man and talk I
think she secretly active and you stop
it enough I think that's why she ripped
your stuff you know I couldn't think she
wanted to stick on us no no [__] that
I'm not in the girls some girls are like
some girls like that to just turn mad on
man yeah I paid good money no no but I
think some girls like a guy that's that
sticks on Prop hotels and puts them in a
place on that yeah but I'm not really I
Won't Say I'm an attack to do that I'm
actually a nice scam nice yeah but they
want to test certain yeah
you get me and tried to take the piss
and then turn around rip my [__] is that
common for women to test boundary and
like keep pushing is that I don't think
I don't think women should do that to
men still especially that I'm asking do
you find it common oh yeah in the dating
Market now what that girls is what goal
out yeah yeah of course they will win it
I think that's common yeah that's just
how it is man you get me but for me
personally I don't think so no no no you
know what everyone weighs up everything
like the intent girls and boys are gonna
weigh up and it's respect and how you
respect yourself it's how someone's
going to respect you so if you carry
yourself in a certain way you can send
people less likely to try it some people
may try it but then when I was saying
that so I thought to myself you know
what what are you saying you've been on
dates and you've not said certain things
before you understand in a way that's
maybe where again there's no wrong right
but that may be the mistake maybe you
have to speak up at a given time
no it is it is well extreme but again
you know it is like and again don't take
anyone away people know that the saying
is frighten yeah people can't be trying
to rip these people's jackets like that
yeah then they gotta think they can do
that it's actually really yeah I I agree
she she must have fought in her head at
the time that she could tear my [__] and
and it's cool yeah she said it went too
far it to me it went way way too trying
to get in the car today
I'm naked
I'm not fully naked but I mean
it went too far from you yeah you know
what I'm getting a cab yeah let me go um
you should have been out yeah
it's all happening remember when you're
getting cups right now you've got to
stand on the road and wait for your cap
to turn up so man's waiting and it's all
going off and I'm like look I'm gonna go
in this cup and I'm gone don't chat to
me excuse me
the way that you said it no but there
weren't much to say I don't know why
she's laughing like that's like see if
she know what I'm saying we don't no I
do I just feel like it seems so like out
of proportion no but [__] you know what
it is um I'm very stubborn yeah oh okay
I don't want to admit it by um I don't
know whether it's with my star sign or
not but I get stubborn so I'll I'll I'm
gonna type a guy to go quiet I won't
argue you won't get into it like that
I'll just switch off yeah I mean and
then I'll get on with what I need to do
I won't I won't do anything else no
screaming shout out the drama guy you
get me I don't like it so it has so did
you ghost her after that or would you do
did I go it goes yeah of course I did
okay I had to there's no way I'm hanging
around someone like that like you
tearing up my clothes and you're making
a fool of me I was just wondering if you
if you told her off or just goes no no I
can't see me I'm a fair guy in it like
if I feel like you done me wrong then
it's cool if we can get through that we
can but if we can't then it's a myth and
I know her attitude was stink you
understand not good it's not good it's
not healthy you understand and plus I'm
in the public eye anyone saw me on road
they were lucky it was a nighttime date
that was Day times too extreme
so I'm glad that yeah yeah you've got to
just pick the right ones in it you gotta
know who you can work with in that sense
and you can't so that one I to go
it's really good did you have a date
that bad no I
don't need to like anything near nearly
as bad as that I mean I haven't had that
many bad dates like most of the dates
that I've been on have been okay the
only thing I can think of is
um it's not even bad it literally sounds
so pathetic compared to what you said
but like we this I went on a date with a
guy and he picked me up and we were
driving to London and we were talking
about like different restaurants and I
was like I like every kind of food apart
from Chinese and then he'd like gone and
booked this Chinese restaurant so like
we had to go and go into the Chinese
restaurant like I didn't like the food
he knew that I didn't like it it's not
that dramatic like yours at all but it's
um it was a bit awkward that's but
that's honestly probably the worst did
you see him after that or no not because
of that but I didn't see him again yeah
so what what made you not see him
he was just he was like really immature
just as a person and we were just quite
different people what what gave you that
impression just because there's guys
watching in the chat so I think they
want to know from like a woman's point
of view yeah
um
I think he like it was something really
small like he asked me where
um I think a part of London was and I
said North West London when it was North
and he got like really like annoyed by
it and I just found it it was it was
just really extreme basically it was
like a really small thing that I got
wrong and he just like took it to heart
so I it after that it kind of put me off
a bit because
why do you care that much just like if
it's north of London or north west but
um to me it's just it yeah it just was
it was really Petty but yeah that's
that's why I entered it not the time I
would have like given him the given him
some slack about the restaurant that
wasn't his full it was just a bit
awkward because we obviously had to sit
there and I didn't like anything on the
menu and but yeah it's more about the
other thing
what do you guys think the biggest thing
that men don't understand about women is
and that women don't understand about
men
oh
maybe I feel like
I as a woman don't understand how men
portray their emotions I find it hard to
like if there was like uh I don't know
how to explain it like
ah wait come back to me I need to word
it in my head before I actually say it
out loud is it is it sometimes like you
don't understand like does your
boyfriend do something where no no no so
like
you've got to come back to me I need to
wear this I need to wear it that's fine
he was yeah sorry so you when you were
saying that I was kind of thinking wrong
she's going to say something about what
men being upset and showing their
emotions like yeah yeah yeah I feel like
you're you're with me yeah I can see you
again with it still so and I sat and I
sat on what I would have said as well
like in life you know I mean men tend to
not you know show their emotions as much
as women Alpha thing yeah in a guy yeah
but I think women like a guy to be more
open and show them yeah yeah you know
what I'm saying but I think as men I
think that's how we grew in it some men
didn't grow with their Dads yeah I had
mommy around yeah so man had to take
that role and be in a strong person I
mean yeah so if Dad was around and man
would see man upset then man might be a
bit more open but I don't know my
circumstances are different my dad went
around yeah I understand but my dad was
there yeah yeah I mean but my dad my dad
passed away um
doing so and so I can't say but yeah
that and um
after that it's like well I never had a
relationship with him but I still
remember my dad and I remember all the
things but I wish he maybe was there at
the start with mile growing because it
might have made me a different guy now
taught you things you didn't know what
I'm saying yeah and and the one thing
was emotions because a lot of us keep
boiling it up and we get angry and we
don't want to show it because we feel
weak yeah I mean but it's not a Dicker
thing to cry you understand or to to be
open and show your emotions you know I
mean I I'm about to learn the hard way
in life with certain things anyway so
I'm only talking from myself you know I
mean I I was one of those guys who who
built up the anger and wanted to just
let out with bear shouting and script
but not crying and but then I learned
that crying is is another healing it's
natural yeah it's a healing I feel like
the people like you coming and talking
about
um emotions being so acceptable and Men
is really important and I feel like it
is you're so right like there's such a
stigma around men having like being able
to be emotional or have like down days
or but I feel like now there's more and
more positive role models coming out and
who are kind of supporting that I think
there should be a stigma around men
being emotional yeah you know yeah yeah
because I think we need strong men in
society I'm not saying like boil it up
and don't talk to anybody but I actually
like don't think Ben should be overly
emotional especially to women because
women I feel like don't like it you know
it's good you know so let me just cut
and I was going to say like crunch to
what you're saying that I think
definitely in this day and age a lot of
men who've been like just brought up by
their mothers single parents but they're
mums now they're very emotional yes and
they've got that feminine traits because
obviously they're getting bang up right
yeah see what he was saying about the
man obviously I don't that's new school
business to me that man making accounts
to
yeah that's that's a joking I don't
think but that's kind of girl business
to me it might I think that's girly
but that's nowadays man's are doing all
these kind of girly of course antique
ginsength
I think you can still be really really
masculine but just be like opened being
a little bit in touch with your emotions
as well yeah but it didn't I mean
masculine well yeah if you're being like
the masculine and men and Old School
menus not really showing your emotions
like that because that's just a man
that's just it doesn't mean you need to
be like wearing your heart in your sleep
all the time but like just being okay
with not being okay right I think
there's a time right I think I think
Society brainwashes men to be women and
I think I think we always we always like
it's really weird because once you see
this you can and see it it's always like
the feminine way to do things always
assumed to be right so like how women
deal with problems that's like assumed
to be correct in society like crying
being emotional like that's assumed to
be the right way to deal with it so it's
like we have a generation of men that
have been told to be women where and
it's like it's it's really because the
psychologists are mostly women the
teachers are mostly met women so it's
like they raise men to be women but like
the way men usually dealt with problems
at least historically was aggression but
like aggression is seen as bad like men
fighting in the schoolyard that's seen
as like a negative thing I like you
poorly man
they pay they paint people that are like
that talk for themselves that have Got
Confidence as a toxic trait as well in
that social media people that are
confident confident and talk up and have
the opinions and have their strong
viewpoints they create that kind of guy
as toxic you know what I mean so yeah
Corky I will talk six or a lot of a lot
of guys don't don't or scared to be
untrue yourself because it's scared to
get canceled because women love cocky
toxic men and I promise you from doing
these shows oh I promise you yeah it's
always like the girl like sometimes
thought like a girl will be arguing with
a guy and saying he's wrong in the whole
show but after she's flirting with him
and I'm like
and so it's like it's like like girls
say they don't like those traits but I
think they genuinely do people like
confident people yeah yeah if you're
confident people are going to like that
I didn't you know what I think with this
whole emotion thing it's easy everyone's
just overly emotional yeah it's way too
yeah but I mean
it's about keeping your emotions in
check but it's not being too overly
happy or too overly sad you understand
having that yeah it's just about a
balance yeah yeah that's what I find it
you know again a lot of men are going on
to fair enough women are more emotional
we know this isn't but nowadays a lot of
men are going over to the emotional side
as well the intensity to me mans need to
kind of pull back I think you can be
emotional without being feminine as a
man like you can be a little bit you can
just be like accept their move on deal
with it in your way without having to
like block it out and hide it and or be
feminine I don't know like a lot of some
of these emotions the internet they
don't really
benefit or help situations and that's
why as a man not really emotional
because it doesn't make that much
difference you know how I'm being an
emotional help a man survive
historically it won't it won't exactly
it won't it's going to get you in
trouble if anything
um I don't agree to us then I hear what
you man is saying
um I won't personally say being
emotional when I was saying being
emotional is be emotional about around
everyone there's certain people to be
emotional around yeah to feel me like if
it's my brother my family people I'm
close to me they can see that I'm not
saying cry around everyone I'm not
trying to tell man be a baby you
understand I'm just saying with the
emotional thing you've got to know who
and who you're being emotional about so
I hear what pearly's saying about yeah I
feel like they should put a stigma in it
but I get you but at the same time if
the man them ain't showing their
emotions yeah when are you going to them
when someone's dead or when certain time
exactly that's right you know what I'm
saying it's not that's not life like but
that's always been like so to be honest
if we look at humans throughout history
like from like like an evolutionary
perspective you know like 10 of um our
ancestors before what's it called like
in the hunter-gatherer days literally
died from uh murder it's like how would
being emotional help you survive back
then when 10 of the people were dying
for murder
crazy so so it's like like men don't
have any biological reason to be
emotional so again we're women we have a
biological reason to be emotional
because if we um got like if we bonded
with the guy like then we would get his
resources right so we have biological
reasons why we're more emotional than
men where men don't so in it and while
we are in 2023 and it is like a modern
world we don't get rid of our biology so
by encouraging men to be emotional it's
like we're encouraging men to be women
wow
crying crying for the right reasons is a
healing bro yeah you've got a question
for the right people understand yeah
yeah so where you're telling me if I cry
it makes me weak or raw I've cried
because now I've got over but she didn't
say weak though no but I'm saying some
people look here as a difference
you know this sounds bad but like I do
think men that like cry are weaker see
in general yeah
hear me out hear me out hear me out
let's see why if we have guy a that
cries 10 times a month and Guy B that
cries zero times a month who's stronger
like I just think like we I know there's
exceptions
that question what she just said dear
the guy say it again let me ask you a
second if guy a cries 10 times a month
and Guy B cries zero times a month cool
who's strong gym every [__] day that
guy there cannot do me nothing I'm
definitely stronger than this done so
there's nothing to do with oh
no no but okay don't make you weaker if
you're quiet I'm sorry it doesn't make
you weaker if you're crying this is what
I'm trying to show the people them which
understand it's not a weak thing when
you're crying it's a releasing it's it's
what's happened and what you're going
through some motions everyone's got
feelings
but I think men are human men have
feelings if they don't let them out and
it's not saying it's gonna punch up the
place they need to go on like Instagram
live and do it in front of everyone or
like they need to do it every single
time they're out but if they don't
they're gonna bottle up those feelings
they're gonna get worse and worse and
then but suicide rates are so high with
men and this is why
I would actually say I would actually
say that suicide rates are high with men
because women ruin them financially and
take away their children in the legal
system and it's legal for them to do so
I would say yeah like they zero out men
at about 45 when they've wasted 20 or
you not wasted but they've spent 20
years of their life building themselves
up having a family and women just say
I'm not feeling it today I'm going to
take your children at half your [__] I
would say that's the real reason and we
have a society of of women telling men
how to be like teaching men how to be
women because it's like again at what
point is the man like is the crying
enough right at what point is he a
strong man you know and I just think
it's lying like the girls and no offense
no offense to you not personally but but
I feel like as women like it sounds nice
to say yeah cry to me however they do
studies on this stuff and women lose
respect for men when they see you cry
and they lose attraction for you so it
sounds nice for me to say yes cry in
front of women that's what I was going
to say being honestly I was going to
stay at school
like kind of deviating it's because
we're speaking about emotions yeah and
that's what like again not say you are
you're not but the monsters start to
jump out of you yeah oh I'm trying to
say is a man you said it's to be able to
control your emotions I'm saying cryo
don't cry it's you gotta be able to
control 100 what we've seen here is
you've got emotions
that you're not necessarily controlling
your emotion and that's where it in
today's society a lot of men uh
emotional and that's why they're doing
erratic things that's why I'm gonna
punch up this and do that but when
you're in control of your emotions
you're insane you're not really going to
be thinking irrational because when
you're women like get emotional and then
they'll start for a couple you are your
boss a joke it is what I'm saying that's
generally yeah women are more emotional
and they're going to do their things
they start with your jacket yeah it's
emotional yeah yeah but men are not
really like that but if you are a man
and you know how to control your
emotions you're not really gonna be
losing it here then everywhere
controlling emotion comes down to the
individual's character you know what I'm
saying to someone goes through certain
Trials of tribulations traumas and stuff
like that and then like they be able to
like if they go through that for me for
instance yeah I've gone through personal
issues like my dad can't saw Here
recently yeah and I went through that
and obviously it hit me hard but
obviously I've been using gym I've been
working on myself mentally I've been
managing emotions through different age
you know what I'm saying to you I think
it's a time and place also to like you
know break down and stuff like that as
well I don't think me Percy I would go
like if I was like seeing something I
wouldn't go to the girl and break down
to her my character I will just do it my
own time because I lacked myself man but
I thought a lot of guys I know a lot of
my friends they will be a bit more
emotional though they'll break down and
and you know they want me to handle
certain things and I think a lot of
females do put a time limit until when
okay cool we've been crying now for like
three months we ain't gonna go and get
your [__] together you know what I'm
saying to yourself a lot of themes will
say oh I want a guy to be a bit more
mostly available
way too much emotionally available then
is that okay cool I've lost a spectator
you know you've been down for like three
months when you're gonna get yourself
[__] together so I think we want strong
men but there is a lot of strong men
though that's the truth
if I was I feel like I'm a strong man
yeah I understand I feel like yeah
does that make me weak listen let me
explain it
I would say it makes you weaker yeah how
many times though I just think it's like
it's like common sense it depends how
many times wait wait wait so guys crying
more than the guy who's not crying like
I don't like what yeah
the person the person who's not crying
is boiling up their emotions they're
going to be emotionally weak their
mental health is going to be right here
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait let me stop let me stop that's
a feminine way to deal with things women
bottle up our emotions and we explode
men are not the same so this is this is
why we're in we're gonna we're in a
feminine like social order where the
woman's like point of view is is assumed
to be everybody's point of view we're
teaching men to have a woman's point let
me bring you down
what you're missing because like early
on when you explain something you said I
go gym so there's no way that man could
happen physically you may be strong men
I'm not saying you are but mentally you
may be weak yeah and when pearly said
about women rinsing out men men get to a
certain age and they commit suicide to
me yeah and I apologies to anyone who's
knows someone who's committed suicide
yeah but those people are mentally weak
because to me like for you to take your
life you're intent because of whatever
circumstances and it meant that has a
knock-on effect for all the people
around your family your friends he said
to me that's weak it's an easy option
out the intent yeah but I'll be honest
with you I know I know I know someone
that's committed suicide and I hear what
you're saying in that but sometimes
you're in it so much and it's like
you're lost your soul because you can
get lost
everyone's got to understand they're
lost because they're not in control of
their emotions yeah it depends on the
person
they're lost because they we live in a
world where literally we teach we have
no direction and they're taught to be
women from like the age of like five
years where they're told don't fight
them oh my God my God being in control
of emotions is skill you know it's a
skills
situations don't even make your break
you know what I'm saying awesome people
around you look me
it's a skill to be able to control your
emotions for men and women it's not a
great thing for even women to be losing
their work and getting over emotional
it's not great like it doesn't serve
anyone any purpose because when you get
angry you start saying things you don't
necessarily mean and it happened a lot
of times in relationship then with women
arguing even in office you don't have
children with no money yeah but like
women actually do get something out of
it sometimes because like there's a
reason we do the things we do right it's
because we can exert control over
menopause exactly and so like that's not
a good thing oh it's not oh I didn't say
it was a good thing I'm saying there's
reasons that we do the things that we do
yeah historical I understand I
understand that but like why do you
think women are always like you ever
been in a relationship and you're like
why is this girl always the victim like
she's a victim
but there's a reason because like
historically they could get resources
and protection from a guy if they were
the victim so there's like biological
reason like we don't undo biology that's
what I'm saying women are small women
are manipulative that's right and men
couldn't never really win but again if
you're in control your emotions and
you've got your good [__] sound
faculties you know what it is you know
women are mostly and you're still
accordingly but I think what you said
where like a lot of men haven't been
taught how to control them that's the
problem wait wait wait so so I think
like but I think your point
um it shows how important it is that
women keep the families together but
right now we're in a society that women
keep breaking up the families because we
we leave men 80 percent of the time and
a lot of the times when men leave it's
like extreme situations like one of the
number one things that she's abusive or
um on substances like when men leave so
it like so it kind of shows like how
important it is that we keep the family
together because we don't like we have
so many emotional men but whose fault is
this is that a job for female to keep to
keep them together yeah 100 a man should
keep the family together that's the
Manchester the man doesn't have a choice
exactly okay if me and you if me and
you're in a relation and I say Aaron you
say I'm staying in this forever we have
a kid where I'm standing this forever
and I say no I'm not feeling it I'm
leaving whose fault is that mine I left
yeah but then there's not I feel like a
lot of men will be affected by that
situation and then you're talking about
all goat into mental health and all
these other things but I feel a man that
things can happen breakups happen all
the time you know I'm saying to you man
can I think they're not carrying his
life yeah exactly adapter move on and
yeah well I agree but it's not that
simple right 100 no it's not that simple
because a lot of times women financially
ruin these men like if you get divorced
it's like you have you have out of all
marriages you have a 15 chance of a
woman maliciously like taking away your
kids and like going out to financially
ruin you so out of every 10 that means
1.5 are like then that's that doesn't
even include the women that still get
child support still get alimons don't
take the kids away so that's one out of
ten where women are going out of their
way to ruin men so it's like it's like
you could say oh just move on but that's
easy some you guys become homeless some
guys don't see their kids like they're
they're taking away everything you know
what I think I think a man prioritizes I
think when a man prioritizes like the
girl his girl over everything that's
when these things can happen I think the
man should be on his purpose and the man
should be on his ground and create like
his purpose and then everything will fit
around you know what he's trying to do
as well sometimes and when a man's just
fully on just trying to make a girl
happy and fully trying to you know
please her all the time and then she
gets frustrated and then you know you
know loses respect for him and then
these things can happen yeah but that's
true but I think but I think that
society makes men do that yeah
just because like think about if me and
you're in a contract and I gain
everything by leaving and you lose
everything by leaving of course you're
gonna do more to make it work how could
you not and and me I'm paid to not make
it work so it's like I think that the
way that the laws are structured
literally influence how we are in
relationships with each other that's
right
many ways get the short end of the stick
no they can't
a lot of people know things but not
everyone accepts it so if you know this
but you also accept it then you're all
right you're in a good place and then
you've controlled the emotion if you
don't accept it you're going to be
pissed that whoa how can I oh women are
going to get it you're done then you're
not going to get emotional because it is
very unfair but then again life's not
fair yeah I mean it's not that every
woman will but it's that every woman can
so if you if you have if you have a
child with a girl because you can avoid
marriage but you can't avoid children
you just have to hope she doesn't do it
that's it there's no real way to avoid
it because men only get custody of their
kids 10 of the time
and and so I do yeah it's like it's it's
real I only know this because I'm doing
a documentary on the UK court system now
so I literally interview these men and
there's some of them where I'm like I
don't know how you could have avoided it
you got a girl that was from a nice home
to parents you had everything like she
had no red flags
and she still they still do it that's
exactly but think about it think about
it it's like okay if stealing was legal
right if it was legal to steal right you
might be a good you know I'm not I'm not
a stealer I don't steal things but you
know if stealing's legal and every day
I'm like tempted looking by all the
people that are stealing I'm walking by
one day I might just do it because it's
legal and the system allows for it so it
doesn't necessarily mean like women are
malicious and out to get you but like
you know it's a lot of power to give one
gender stuck in their favor that's right
yeah
but it goes back to like the society
where we always view the woman as the
victim like I forgot I mean do you guys
know anyone that's been falsely accused
of a crime like a guy yeah understood
and like most of society just believes
her right is that even if you're seeing
football like you see that rapists is
that you know rapists grapefest
graveless but you see um like when you
have situations like that you know
everyone just believes that that it's a
guy that did it you know what I'm saying
just because of what so that you you
know the image without betrays in it so
yeah therefore yeah it's it's another
interesting point again when you talk
about like women you were saying earlier
about a lot of men not getting like not
having sex basically and again it's
because women
they can be more picky because they're
ultimately the ones saying yes or no you
can't have sex with a woman unless she
says yes yes and where's guys you can
send us what guys are gonna this sound
is gonna be low they're gonna get
anything they can you know unless you're
in a certain fraction of man yeah and
then your kind of options a bit more
yeah and when it's interesting because
we're the it's like an unprecedented
time in history because women are 100 in
control of who's born where historically
like the men would impregnate the woman
if you didn't comply you know they're
gonna grape you you know like so
historically like like men have always
been in control of reproduction where
now women are for the first time ever in
history with abortion being legal right
and men like you have no safe exactly
yeah and she ended a stick again yeah so
like when you think about it women are
100 in control of relationships and sex
so it's like if it goes south like how
can we not say it's on the women because
we're 100 in control exactly and that's
it again it's good that you're saying
all these things because they're real
the fact that people probably don't who
don't even want to agree with him
because they sound kind of a bit funny
but it's still it's the realist yeah
well and it's not to hate on women like
I I think any group that has a
significant amount of power like I heard
I was just interviewing this guy who's
like uh he made this book called the
history of sex today and he was talking
about how back before like you know in
order to satisfy like the the one out of
three men that are either like the the
sexless men in the tribe because if you
didn't give them sex like now we have
corn but before they didn't so you had
to give them something otherwise they
get angry and start to Riot so they
would literally like take a girl and
make her have sex with like 20 dudes
yeah yeah like that's what they would do
historically but now it's like this is
the first time where women are in
control 100 control of sex and
reproduction
having sex with the guys and no no like
like so before the women had to comply
with what the men like the strongest
fittest men wanted so if you were in a
guy's like with the his tribe or
whatever and they're protecting you and
he says go sleep with 20 men you got to
do it right what are you gonna do so
let's switch now so now the switch now
is that like women are 100 in control of
who's born because we are in control of
abortion right so and we are 100 control
of birth control so if maybe if there's
a male birth control that was like the
equivalent because okay if I sleep with
if I sleep with you right I we we both I
know a hundred percent like all the the
facts about the sex we're having right
because like I know if they're wearing a
condom or not that like that's the only
form of birth control that men have but
women it's like you don't know if I'm
ovulating or not you don't know if I'm
on birth control or not you don't know
if I'm going to take the plan B you
don't know if I'm going to go get the
abortion yeah and so that's what I'm
saying like women are 100 in control now
and you could even say women are 100 in
control of relationships because what
comes first sex or relationships
nowadays in 2023 yeah you've said it
ready sex isn't it yes sex and so it's
like it's like if if that's the case
then women are 100 in control yeah women
yeah that's right women aren't control
these days well again if you're
like a masculine man and you you
understand keep two years and there must
have been ways women are still going to
the incentives
they still sleep with 20 guys they just
aren't told
that when you said it because women now
like they're happy to sleep around with
more than one guy at a time insane where
that was kind of
a lot more taboo nowadays it's not
really out accepted but it's like a lot
of the rappers and these filming rappers
they've made it kind of like trendy to
do that like well you could sleep around
off that if your man ain't saying one
you can dissemen you need to move over
to the next Mile and again it puts a lot
of pressure on men in sex as well you
understand again it's very
um it's yeah no it's just it's the truth
it's it's very that if a man comes quick
I hear you he's gonna get shunned but if
a woman comes quick then no one says
anything but if you're having sex and
sex is about having fun and pleasuring
each other shouldn't really make that
much difference but again there's a lot
of pressure again many ways get the
short end of six that you can't you
can't win
that's mad you know to hear it as well
as that's the sounds like you said this
they masculated exactly
exactly that's why man might have to
keep strong and keep firm and keep their
emotions under control when you do that
then women will you insane but you need
you know is it's easier said than done I
think a lot of people struggle because
there's no one around them to as people
get a lot of guys get bad of us you know
get bad advice no no I don't need it
myself
but I'm saying a lot of money a lot of
money no the trees are not a man get bad
of us some other other guys as well you
know what I'm saying that could
influence them to like not be able to
make because manage emotions like it's a
skills you have to go through certain
situations because I feel like as a man
a man golf in certain situations trials
and tribulations that and then yes this
character
will get tested through these situations
and it's up to him to like you know
when his character gets tested for him
to you know okay cool I've gone through
this now
um I learned from this and enabled to
like become more stronger yeah you can't
just be like have a school where it's
like okay imagine more she doesn't
you're not born to manage your emotions
everything's gonna take practice and
over time yeah but it goes back to like
keeping the family together because like
how is it how is a man gonna learn from
a woman how to control his emotions you
can't but I'll be honest with you I
don't even believe that as well because
in my situation like my family's been
together but it's been so that kind of
like all these arguments and stuff like
that and you can see that in certainly
my situation like you know you know um
I've been around like a lot of emotional
men in my family and stuff like that so
it's you know and that can make someone
like you know go over the edge but you
have to learn again from understanding
situation and learn and adapt and see
what it is but I thought a lot of people
can be in situations and some of my
friends as well in situations whereby
they've grown with their mom and they've
grown with that as well but because it's
in a toxic kind of like
um scenario what no what not they're
able to like you know be able to manage
emotions they get frustrated and and
then they go through no [__] as well I
think the state of relationships makes
like relationships worse so the state of
marriage and like long-term
relationships how like our Our
Generation really like even knew it when
you said six years I was like I don't
know the last time I've had someone on
the show in a relationship for more than
six years right and and so like that
being impressive is a little sad when
you think about it it's happy for you
but no but think about it no no think
about it it's happy for you but just
like it shows the state of society but
it's like because we're always hat we
both parties mostly women have one foot
out the door all the time it's gonna
change the way you argue because every
argument you're not thinking about a
solution you're thinking should I leave
or should I go or before marriage was
for life so you had to stick that [__]
out so you had to think of the solution
because you couldn't go get divorced I
feel like it's a bit of a domino effect
though that like it's gone so far the
other way where that is a new Norm but
if we start moving it back the other way
more people will jump on that if that
makes sense and that that will become
eventually like the new Norm again we're
getting married again no for people to
stick at it and stay together yeah I
think if if women chose to do that but
we have to like you have to convince the
women right we've got a job to do but
but even even so it's like I don't think
I don't think we can ever really go back
to the way it was until they get rid of
no fault divorce because what's marriage
marriage isn't marriage today like if
you get married in the church it's not
the same thing as it was because the
average marriage is eight years so like
what what are you getting out of
marriage you're not getting a lifelong
Commitment if the women are leaving
that's true and so it's like now like
marriage is supposed to be for sicker
for poor and or for richer for poorer
and sickness and health health for
better for worse now it's until I'm not
happy we're all so it's it's not the
same it's not the same same thing like
how could it be the same thing it's just
like it might as well just be a
relationship yeah but a lot of guys
don't want to marry those oh a lot of
guys are happy to be in relationships
I'm not married but do you think that's
maybe because they're just they just
think that the divorce stories are so
high I think it's a financial thing as
well like and I think that also like if
you've been grinding and you've worked
your way up to some sort of level
success and you meet someone on that
journey and it's like okay cool
um you know you don't want to like you
know because you've got a 50 50
interview marriage and okay cool you
don't have to but I thought a lot of
guys think about financially other
things as well that can imply as well
when you married as well yeah like one
incentive like what do men get out of
marriage today nothing but it's not bad
money though is it it's not a lot of it
is
like marriage for women is kind of like
a fantasy sucker yeah
yeah you still so yes I mean it's
I don't want to say it's unrealistic
because again it's to the individual but
it's
it's all of that for one day a lot of
money fairy tale bro yeah it depends on
the one day and really that money could
be but if the relationship if you are
serious about the ministry that money
probably could be better spin the incent
in the right place yeah finessing the
relationship
I heard that depends on your budget I
guess yeah that's right that's
definitely the truth that could be rich
so you could have a rich wedding yeah
I've seen it all and then again that
more alludes to the whole fantasy type
of thing because if the budget is
massive you're gonna go big and dude
well I think go crazy actually a
marriages last shorter the more they
spend on the on the wedding yeah because
yeah that would make sense because again
like if a lady is really in love with a
man he intended the man's got a small
budget for a wedding but she's really in
love him she's going to go on it and
really maximize it because not the money
they spent it's the happiness and the
enjoyment if a woman's with a guy and
he's got loads of money they go big on a
wedding it wasn't really about of good
love yeah it was more about the fantasy
yeah the fantasy and the whole dream and
the all of that kind of stuff so and
again these These are fundamentals do
you think you can have it both you can
have the The Big Wedding and that and
love
yes you can could anything's possible
the internet is it's going to be a very
small percentage that's going to be
happening with at the end and if we're
breaking it down but yes it's definitely
definitely possible
I feel like the chances are so small it
would be like two people who have come
up together like you know I mean yeah
yeah yeah that's right yeah that would
be yeah that would be a good way of
looking at it the intent
yeah and even like back in the day a man
used to get something out of marriage to
get a virgin or at least a girl with
like a low body count but nowadays it's
like what percent of women are virgins
on their wedding night so they used to
get Purity in Youth and now the average
age of first marriage is like 28 or no
it's 31 in the UK and so it's like
they're not getting a young girl anymore
they're not getting a virgin anymore
it's like what what do they get out of
marriage
but do you think that now like because
women
have more like their careers are
different now so more like back in the
day women weren't so career orientated
but now maybe women are a bit more
career orientated so the money might
come equally from the women and the man
so it might not even be like that the
man needs to get something out of it it
could be more equal I'm not saying
that's good or bad but what's he getting
out of it then
the same as what the woman's getting out
of it
what the women gets protection and
provisioning and they get that the
fantasy day the dress and uh walking
down the island all that stuff yeah guys
not really you just get respect internet
well I mean I do agree with you that's
it I found this out today when I was
talking to the like I forgot what his
job title he wrote a really big book but
but basically like when women um the
biggest Factor that's played in women
are like kind of the breakdown of the
family was in the 20s women started
going
um like that was when they started they
used to stay with their Dads until they
would get married so their dads would
find them their husband basically and
then like they never lived on their own
but like that's when women started
having kids less and that's when like
the age of first marriage started going
up was when women started entering the
workforce yeah the feminist movement
yeah yeah again and defense movement is
to to my knowledge is that like a big
breakdown in society families the intent
it's kind of changed the whole Dynamics
and now women are yeah a lot more do it
themselves and more powerful and stuff
like that and a lot of women are saying
this they don't need a guy and stuff
like that just change the whole
polarities and again it's made men a lot
more
weak or emotional and how things kind of
I've just found out the other day it
came from witchcraft too like a lot of
the things that you hear girls say like
goddess Queen like that sort of thing
it's actually like originates from like
some sort of wit I'm butchering it but
it's some sort of Witchcraft yeah yeah
I'm serious because it was like it was
like it was like this girl that like
like she wanted to like put down men so
a lot of a lot of the sorry I'm
butchering it so much because it's not
off the top of my head but it's like a
lot of like the trends that we see like
people think that feminism is about
equality but it's really not it's about
Freedom at the expense of men and it's
like now that women have gotten the
freedom to vote like what have we done
with it we've built a society that puts
down men
women a lot of women don't respect men
nowadays and that's a the internal big
fundamentals why certain people are
going to rip people's coats and all
these type of things they said what what
age group are we talking about here
because what you're saying could be for
the other generation the older lot now
the younger lot it's not like that
they're still trying to like I know I
don't know but personally how I see it
how I see the youngers moving these days
they're packing up together easy girl
ain't moving with that energy that they
have the power you get it man them are
moving like they can run things
you see it no but see you're correct
you're correct but it's a small
percentage of men okay so so before 30
women women go for the 20 of men
typically okay so it's like like
basically like women go for the 20 of
men and then they hit 30. remember
geriatric pregnancy starts at 35 and if
a woman hits 30 and she's single she has
less than a 50 chance of having a kid
because there's going to be more single
childless women than literally ever in
history it's like unprecedented because
if a woman hits if she's still single at
30 that means that like she has to get
to a point that she has to get the guy
to like marry her so we're gonna see
more single childless women and and the
thing is
um
the the issue is for I forgot where I
was gonna end I forgot what there's a
question no I was just chatting about
Network I said uh the age group in it
what age group are you on oh oh and so
so the men sorry I forgot for a second
I'll go on tangents but so that so the
men in in the women in their 20s are
dealing with the top 20 of men maybe 30
of men then they get closer to 30 they
start to go for the top maybe like the
next 20 or 30 amount right and and we
get this data from dating apps too and
and also like I don't know just they
they do they do stuff to figure this out
yeah and so the issue is that like those
men have all the leverage and and so
those men get that treatment but women
don't treat the average men well the
average guy that works at Tesco the
average guy that works like down the
street the ones what know how to pattern
yeah they're the ones who get dealt with
differently this is why when she when
you're saying that the power is there
and the women and it's harder for men in
my time the time that's not the case
different set up forget me yeah so it's
obviously an age group thing it's it's
more again it's personal it's what you
do you're out there you understand yeah
the comparison was like and again
there's nothing wrong with working in
Tesco's or driving a box of being a road
sweeper there's absolutely nothing wrong
with that is that Society kind of looks
down in it but in front of your your
kind of your name brand we're gonna put
your enzyme so your experience is going
to be different than the next month's
experience at that the intense it's hard
for you to see it yeah in my side of
this that's what that's where you're
challenging that yeah that's what I was
trying to work out but I hear you that's
what I'm saying I understand now yeah
you're not you're in that I'm not in
that side no and I think I honestly
think like women have subtle misandry
that we just don't see every day and I
you know I'm not even going to say I've
never said anything like anything like
that you know like we hear like men are
trash men are the problem but if a guy
goes on social media and says women are
[__] they're they're looked down upon
even if that's more true when you think
about it because women 100 years ago
only 15 admitted to having premarital
sex yeah to now where what percent of
women are virgins on their wedding night
so if you look at the difference in
women like women are that's kind of just
a fact in general right but men are
ashamed for saying that but women can
say men are trash men are the problem
men are this men are that yeah true and
they're sick again when they come you
can't it's the society and then come up
with you you're getting bash lift right
in center yeah
it's true though women women do run a
lot of you know the society in the setup
but
maybe that is the right thing maybe that
is the best way I don't know I would
never know in it that is my meant to
have power over I don't think it's the
best
I just feel like I don't know like I
think that's in my head that's how it's
been planted and years ago yeah you know
you know why because it's natural again
what what's happened from my viewpoint
in society things have veired away from
just naturalness and and just in general
people fade away from nature nature
teaches a lot of people like how things
are and just natural naturally men are
leaders naturally men are stronger than
women equal but different
but in life nothings equal though
in life nothing's actually equal and
again it's accepting that inside it's
accepting that no why don't you disagree
I do think men and women are completely
equal it's just those different
qualities
how would you say that different
qualities just equal is equal equals 50
50. what do you mean by equal equal and
what in running Society equal just in
like respect for each other and like
what we bring is what we all bring to
the table it's just so different so I
would disagree when it comes to running
Society so in in a society we need men
more like no I'm not talking about like
women need to raise the family right but
but you also need men so we like we've
seen what happens when fathers aren't in
the home so men and women are equally
they they I think needed in the family
but when it comes to running a society
most of the jobs that run the
infrastructure of society so like the
policemen the power lines the K like all
the things women's jobs could go away
tomorrow Society would still run because
you know what what women are
construction workers if women are in
construction they're like in management
or some [__] job that we don't
really need let's just be honest where
men are the ones doing the hard like the
hard jobs the street the street sweepers
the sewage like all the stuff that like
if went out tomorrow society would not
run yeah I think about even an army
think about having [__] it's a fun lot
you're not going to send a woman on the
front line to go fight for your country
your mind's going to be in the front and
I'm fighting defending for this country
you know what I'm saying that's the
thing like there's nothing wrong with
accepting that men and women are not
equal
not the same is the same it's the same
equal not the same it's but I mean
equals and like they're both like
equally as worthy and like have equally
important parts but they're just
different well
but I guess important in what yeah
that's what I'm saying because what
pearly just said that example is a good
example the internet like if women I
never thought of that before but what is
a very good example so
they're not really equal in in that
respect there I mean and I don't know
where you could say that they are equal
but it'd be a good question to ask I
would say equal but different like
obviously different's different and
equals equal but I would say definitely
equal I mean
what I mean women bring men and women
bring people into the world like we give
birth men don't do that so they were not
equal in that respect because men can't
believe but when it comes to
reproduction I think we I think we mean
but we're we're getting it a bit
converted but I think I think the
difference is like we're in in running a
fan like in in having a kid like women
give birth yes but men have to
impregnate her and when you think about
it like women can only give birth to
like one kid at a time where men can
impregnate like multiple women at a time
so when you when you think about it like
in society no no I'm not gonna die on
that Hill never mind but but you see
when it comes to like the way Society
runs like women need men more than men
need women
we need more of you talking
100. we don't hear that enough yeah not
in the UK you get me remember the
question is why like why don't we hear
that enough and and the thing is like I
genuinely think society's been
brainwashed to like think that we don't
need men like why do we even have IVF
why is that even an option like that
like why are women going to to like to
volunteer to be a single mother yeah
that's meant think about they're paying
to be a single mother if they don't find
a guy in time that's true but cotton IVF
B for medical reasons see yeah I know it
can
um but even is that the greatest idea
exactly yeah probably not yeah yeah and
it fails most of the time that's the
other thing is like like again we don't
really talk about the real numbers when
it comes to fertility like 90 of your
eggs are gone by 30. so if you don't
have a kid by 30 like you have a leftist
then if you're not in a relationship you
have less than 50 chance of having a kid
so you're more likely to not have a kid
than have one but we tell women oh wait
wait wait you're fine when it's like
really I mean you're on crunch time and
that's right the other the IVF and stuff
like that and it goes back to this thing
where I'm saying it's not actually
natural yeah yeah it's not something
naturally if let's just say a woman
couldn't have a child that's natural
that's actually how it happened and what
it was that's actually natural and you
just have to live with it again it's not
going to be the nicest scenario but then
again maybe you've got your next views
or your nieces and stuff like that so
you can still be Dr says that takes a
village to to grow a child you know so
you still put your input in in the end
but it just so happens that naturally it
was a juice yeah for you
again it's it's these things seem harsh
but they're not really against when you
just look it's natural this is nice it
is what it is but again when you
understand it and accept it then it's
sad isn't it that's emotional no it's
not really even sad I don't think it's
sad no hey
you know what why is it sad I mean if
anything we we live in a more free
Society than ever as women
let me just save the situation
[Music]
it's perception yeah it's because you've
got your nieces you've got your nephews
the essence you've still got children
yeah I grew up a lot with my aunt to
intent and finally it's actually weird
I'm not moving forward but that
three the answer I've grown up with they
haven't got children but I'm like their
child I'm it's like I've almost got four
months and then because they are like
yeah but we're gonna we're gonna have an
unprecedented amount of unprecedented
amount of men and women that wanted
children that will not have them they're
protecting 50 like 50 of women that hit
hit 30 or single and childless remember
geriatric pregnancy starts I wonder if
adoption will go up because of that
adoption and or like bring it in from
other countries is where we'll go up
um I I
prob maybe probably but again you know
I've been on both sides of adoption
where like my mom gave up a kid for
adoption with my dad because my mom and
dad got pregnant when my mom was a
teenager she was like young and so they
gave that kid up and then we also
adopted three teenagers wow yeah yeah
but that's it's not good for a kid like
there's a lot of problems that come with
it like even if you get them young
remember like most kids develop by the
age of three so it's and and the thing
is
if you don't because the issue with
adoption it's actually not hard to get a
kid adopted like they always talk about
these kids in the foster care system the
issue is the mother's weight or the
mothers are on drugs or something so
they take the kids away later and the
kids are too messed up so and like who
wants like a four-year-old that's been
with a crackhead for four years yeah you
know not true yeah same kind of thing
yeah same kind of things no when you
chase things back that's how I always go
through life just thinking natural what
would be the natural way to go around
this what is a natural how is this done
and then if you kind of stick to that
kind of line you don't go too far along
but it's interesting because like again
this unprecedented like level this
unprecedented number of people that want
children that will not have them is
happening because women are in control
of reproduction I didn't know about the
age
um like when your first your eggs I
didn't know that and I actually wanted
to wait until I was 30 to have kids but
now that I know this like you're saying
people can't have kids because they find
out too late I literally wouldn't have
known if you didn't tell me yeah and the
and the thing is the women that do IVF
like it mostly fails yeah that's the
other thing they don't say the majority
of women do it that do it fail yeah the
chances are really bad yeah the good
thing is when now you're thinking about
this you have to tell your partner and
then include him because again it goes
wrong because women are in control of
this now you think oh I want to have a
baby but the intent and this is where a
lot of Mix-Ups happen in relationships
yeah women want to have the kids man
don't necessarily want to have the kid
they've had sex yes and without a condom
or whatever she's got pregnant he's got
no choice in saying whether he even if
again it goes both ways it's listening
to say he didn't want a child you
understand he can't there's nothing he
can do basically and it's to say he does
want the child and the woman doesn't
want a child again there's nothing he
can do so again you get the short end of
the stick she's shabby so it's this way
communication was going to be a really
big part
like exactly you said in it
exactly now we'll get into the Crux of
it life isn't fair so that's why you
have to be in control because if a woman
now has a baby
he said now what you're going to do
you're going to jump up a bridge you're
going to start crying you're gonna what
are you gonna do yeah you have to hold
it yeah and control your emotions and do
what the right thing is going to be
incense
what control emotion that's that top
personal men with to do that a lot of
money that's a bit harsh sorry to cut
your brother when he says control your
emotions yeah I tried to work it out
like what he's saying here because it's
not easy for people who are going
through a bad time in Life or you know I
mean they're laughing with the greatest
yeah I mean I'm not one of them I'm cool
but I've seen a lot of people go through
hard times and I get messages here and
then whatever and they can't control
their emotions
a bad word yeah they can if they really
wanted to you understand but when you're
in a dark hole bro explain to me how you
do you do
and again you have to like be in tune
and in alignment with yourself exactly
and you know yourself just the way
you're speaking because think about this
like think about how soft we are as a
society we live in the most free Society
ever the most safe Society ever and yet
we have more mental health issues than
ever think about it our ancestors 10 of
them died from murder everyone was
getting killed wow and now it's like
they're coming to us and saying this is
what you guys are whining about there's
no Wars there's no like but it's crazy
because if we never put this into
perspective because we're just
brainwashed yeah that's about to say it
that's what I think it is they've
they've Brainwashed the nation on
purpose yeah
like they make us think we're oppressed
they make us think that like we have no
choice they make us like they're
literally trained like I think they're
training you to like training us yeah I
thought Society is training a man like
to to steal his drive like make him not
have ambition and have drive and hunger
to be weak yeah 100 yeah but this again
this is all on purpose what 100 is it
generally a whole nother podcast but
this is it's not an accident that this
is happening in this so prevalent right
now and they're and they're training
women to be men when you think about it
like like I mean they have the saying in
the red pill or it's like if a girl's
single by like I don't know 27 26 30
roughly like they've become the men that
they wanted to marry because most of the
things that like they like we would look
for we've become so yeah I do agree I
think there's like that we need to go
back to how it used to be like with the
more traditional person name with more
traditional roles and like we've
completely lost that 100 and I think
it's important I think women need the me
personally for I feel like women need
the men to take that traditional male
role and the the men need the women to
kind of be in their feminine a bit more
what's my take on it yeah but I think
the problem is like are women going to
become more traditional like what
percent of women
like the problem is it has to start with
us because like we can't ask for
traditional outcomes if we're not
traditional women like what percent of
women are waiting until they're married
I mean that you can't work and you can't
have a career and stuff but I guess it's
just no it doesn't mean you can't like
have a job like you have to eat so I'm
not saying you can't have a job and be a
traditional woman but like what percent
of women really know how to cater and
respect a man like what percent of women
have like I don't know I had this um
girl and she worked in corporate
actually she came and she taught an
episode of wife School the one I was
talking about in the beginning and she
um she worked in Corporate America but
like just her presence was so calming
like haven't you ever been around a
mother or Grandma it's usually not women
in our generation it's like a generation
or two above us where it's like they
they have all these original recipes
from scratch like you come in they take
off your like they might take off their
husband's shoes like they're very like
they're so comforting but it's like what
percent of young women are like that
anymore know how to do it and is that
really like it's not necessarily our
fault like we've been brainwashed and a
lot of us didn't have mothers that
respected our fathers you know so like
what percent of women have really seen a
mother respect her father but the
problem is like we have to start it
otherwise there's going to be no change
because we have all the power yeah I
agree I really do agree it doesn't mean
like I don't think that's it's just
going back to how it kind of used to be
a little bit I think that is knee dead
yeah man that's the final offense are
gonna happen man I think I think I think
it's Society insults me that's we feed
on toxic stuff we feed on like the whole
drama do you know what I'm saying to you
that's music yeah we're seeing movies
like come on man's watching stuff yeah
and getting gas yeah think about it are
there going to be more women and only
fans in the next 10 years or less
lessons
obviously but I'm saying when they put
more money into this only fans thing
you'll find you not saying new person
but you'll find girls your age jumping
on the boot in like yes yes if it's
Global and they're making cash it's an
income you little skin out battery out
you put them out okay
okay do you think do you think that the
teenagers nowadays sleep with more or
less people than the teenagers of 10
years ago more okay right right so it's
not going in the right direction and
that's the problem so it's like we say
to Matt like let's go back but it's like
the men are like okay take the first
step get married young don't sleep with
everybody and then the girls are like ah
maybe not that
I have an opinion but it's very
controversial take I don't know what
it's called here but in the U.S you know
what the 19th amendment is no so the
19th amendment was when we gave women
the right to vote I say repeal the 19th
no no
I'll tell you why you know why you think
this is crazy you've never heard it
before and when I first heard this I
thought it was nuts but hear me out okay
why are the laws so unfair against men
like we agree okay would you agree that
the way relationships are are in part to
do with the way that the laws
systematically discriminate against men
yes okay why are these laws there why
why can't we this is an open oppression
on the bro like even until I don't know
a couple years ago male grape wasn't
even on the books so these are laws that
are a hundred percent unfair why I I
think personally like you said before is
the women having more of a speech like a
a say so they've got more power so now
you lot can you know say take Direction
in them type of things there's more
women voting than Matt there's more
women on the planet but do you know I
think how it used to be was so wrong
like women didn't have a say they didn't
they weren't even there for a full
person like they that the way it used to
be back in the day was too far the other
I I used to think that but no I think we
were brainwashed to think that because I
started to look into the anti-suffrage
right so so the women that said no
because the majority one thing we don't
know the majority of women didn't want
the right to vote they didn't want it so
I was thinking why wouldn't women want
it why are they giving us something we
didn't want so I look into the writings
of the anti-suffrage it's talking about
they said this is the end of the
breakdown of the family when I get
married I'm one with my husband why do
we need two votes they're trying to
break up the family like if you believe
in traditional relationships you believe
in submitting to your husband's
Authority why doesn't he have the
authority to vote for the family so I I
think that was the beginning of the
breakdown of the family because then you
have the politicians they can't go
against women because then they won't
get reelected that would make sense I
totally agree and when I said earlier
the feminist movement is similar thing
that I learned basically when they
allowed women to vote it was two things
basically
um
they were going to earn more money
because after women start to vote then
women start to start working and they're
taxing everybody so not the first they
were taxes only men so they're getting
that money but then women started
working so taxi women said getting more
money but also when women started
working it broke down the family because
now they're at work so who's looking
after the kids the state the schools are
looking after their kids and schools as
we know it yeah I don't know if everyone
knows it schools are just brainwashing
kids they're not actually teaching kids
about anything not teaching kids about
love my teaching kids about actually
making money or doing anything it's just
brainwashing kids to go to the program
learn program come out of school and
work and then be in the system and earn
the system more money so that is exactly
where and the other thing is teachers
teachers are like 80 to 90 women
nowadays I heard some guys on the like I
heard some guy say on the dating app so
it's like a red flag there's a bunch of
like old teachers on it I don't I don't
know you can tell me if that's true or
not true I don't know what it's like to
date a teacher but but but
so it's like you you know again we're
going and and the thing is the the
problem like we get with single parent
homes right is a lot of times like the
women don't know how to discipline the
kids or they don't know how to like like
because men men are actually better with
kids over the age of seven so a lot of
times people think like kids are
automatically better with the mother not
true they're they're better with the
mother under the age of like I don't
know seven six something like that so so
because the problem is like when women
like if you want to discipline like like
let's say you hit a kid right the
woman's emotion is like oh you poor baby
like coddle them where the men's emotion
is not he deserved that [__] because
like men are more structured and so now
we have like all of these women that are
like raising the kids in the schools
we're not raising them to be men they're
raising them to be women
but yeah they've got that thicker around
I'm sure it should go the way it should
go which is balanced
if they have a dad no it's bad yeah it's
better to have a dad figure but it's
what's happening is what Society has
done but they don't want to eradicated
but who who influences
think about it now now we don't have
them in the schools now right now why
don't we have them in the schools think
about it so it now like men are getting
allegations of like like they can be
metooed in the school and there's not
really a monetary payout and like men
aren't really like male teachers aren't
really respected women don't like what's
the incentive for men to want to be
teachers there's not really one so it's
like they go to the school and who
influences your kid more if they go to
school seven hours a day Mr teachers
yeah teachers yeah and so now you have a
society where the the teachers are
influencing the kids more than the the
parents and like I've even seen this
firsthand like my my family's very
conservative right you know like die
hard and low taxes whatever right and
you know my one sister is a die-hard
liberal and where did this come from it
didn't come from our house well it came
from like her I don't know her horse
trainer was super liberal her friends at
school were super liberal and so now
like she has these completely different
values to what my family's values are
because they're like brainwashing them
in the school they showed her you know
you know what CNN is yeah I was like I
don't know if you guys have seen it on
here yeah I don't want to watch TV but
but so they were showing my little
sister CNN which is a very left-wing
organization in the school why are they
teaching that to my sister why are they
showing that to them in the schools our
virginities as well like LGBT the other
things as well their permission as well
yeah I have a friend who she said her
sister was like bi or something like she
only dated girls and she said that she
felt like her sister wasn't really gay
and um it was just like her friend group
in the school told them it was like and
we're seeing it in the trends too
because it's like seven percent I think
it's seven percent no I think it's
higher than that it's a super high
percentage of kids under the age of like
18 that identifies lgbtq plus whatever
is influence it's all influence yeah and
it's on purpose this is again
though this is what I'm saying you see
me blood I'm 35
[Music]
but I'm just saying like in my time in
school there was men teachers there was
girl teachers you know when they get to
how this is that and they weren't all
feminine the new generations and it's
set up different and this is what they
want us to see it's what the society is
done they've done this to man yeah right
well the thing this is like a covert
movement and it's been going on for a
long time they're just slipping it in
seven percent since we gave them the
right since we gave us the right to vote
yeah exactly and that's how they they're
getting there this was a big turning
point for me because I always thought
there was waves of feminism so I thought
first wave feminism good second wave
feminism last good third wave feminism
evil but it's all one movement and it's
the same movement because they want the
freedom without the responsibility it's
the same thing with voting right because
think about it before if you voted you
have to get drafted so it like so in the
U.S I don't necess I really should look
up how it works here because I talk
about this so much but in the US we're
voting for the commander-in-chief of the
military because what is the consequence
if all hell breaks loose in the U.S we
have to go to war right now who goes to
war the men so the women are voting in a
system that they didn't help build and
they're not a part of like why do we
have the right to do that against
freedom without the responsibility
because you guys are the ones that are
gonna have to go fight and even and and
the other thing is we have selective
service now what is selective service
that means that in a time of or you have
to be drafted so like we don't have the
official draft nowadays but they just
call it something else so if like all
hell breaks it Loose you have to go to
war now and I think that's fair like if
you're living in a country you should
have to defend it right I mean if [__]
goes south I I think that's a fair
system however the thing is we know damn
well women aren't going to be on the
front line so we're voting for a system
and and the thing is I think if you're
voting for a system you have to have
some skin in the game like you have to
be a part of the consequence it's like
benefits like you're if you're the one
living off of the benefits you're gonna
vote for benefits forever so why is that
fair if you if you have no skin in the
game it's Chevy you know and one one
really quick sorry there's a 200 Super
Chat gotta chat but keep preaching for
all your mods are legit they need a
raise
I just thank you Lucas for the Super
Chat sorry go ahead
no I was going to say you know it's an
interesting point you said that if you
live in a country you should defend it
and I disagree with that that Muhammad
Ali was a good person but he said when
America was going to war and he said you
know the Vietnamese didn't they haven't
done me anything so why am I going to
fight them obviously they put him in
prison they took his ways belts but
again he stood for what he believed in
and I I can
it's a 50 50 but again I really I
respect him because you know what he
stood up for what he he believed in the
end I mean I don't I don't really know
much about Muhammad I'm gonna be on like
so I don't I don't want to step on like
the Madame alleys fans
sorry okay I don't know much about it
but but like in my opinion it's like
well you're living and you're choosing
to live in the benefits of a country so
you could do you get safety security
benefit like you get all the Privileges
of being in said country like why would
you not have to defend it just because
you agree with the the leader it's like
if you work for a certain company right
and the boss makes a decision you don't
like why like you still have to go with
it in my opinion anymore that's right
but again this is this one's gonna go
like a lot deeper because remember
ultimately he's been bringing to the
country and it's a it's a bully boy
thing and what America does or are doing
is again some it's bully boy business
they're going to places and invading
taking over against Power and they want
it's what they obviously want to do are
you saying well why should I be a part
of that question well I think you move
stop living off the benefits you know
what I mean it sounds like the thing is
with Muhammad Ali and with America
and it this afternoon it's going to go
back way way far you'd have to say the
Americans have to move because they've
come there and he was already or his
ancestors are there they've come and
against bully boy business I don't get
it they've come and they've you know
bullied invaded
yeah it's bullying they're bully you're
going to places and bullying places for
their resources and taking over them and
yeah that's always been yeah oh yeah
yeah throughout all of history there's
been people like stronger people like
beat we like that's that's throughout
all of history so my thing is like if
you're going to take all the benefits of
living in a country like how can you
like like so you take all the like let
me live here and have no skin in the
game and complain and complain but it's
like okay then live in a different
country that aligns more with your
beliefs and people are doing it nowadays
like I know so many people that are
moving to Dubai because they can't they
can't stand the West it doesn't align
with their values their vision for the
future exactly exactly that's exactly
right I don't know what I mean you know
he went into jail and in Kmart Joe
obvious he was a heavyweight champion
old school days isn't it yeah so
definitely old school days where they
look into them it's interesting very
interesting character very outspoken and
stood for what he what he believed in
what what makes you so what you're kind
of red pill I see it kind of yeah would
you say you're kind of red pill I see it
what does that mean it just means like
you like when I said the voting thing
most people's gut reaction is Ah that's
horrible but you're the only one nodding
yeah no could I agree with that oh you
really wouldn't be saying about the
women yeah yeah yeah no I'm just curious
where does that come from like where did
you learn that
um
I've got a background research funny no
again my mama's got very expensive why
are you laughing it's the way you dream
about my business started
a lot of people aren't yeah
take your time
yeah I can't give you a wrong answer
you have to make sure it connects yay
but you know my mom and saw some really
good values yes and my dad is a very
much a man's man he's and he stood some
very again people say it's very harsh
but
it's it's a really sense and he
understands about being a man and what
it takes to be a man and my mom also
understood her feminine role but then
she's also got some
hello
I don't want to say masculine traits but
again she's a she's a realist the
internet yeah they installed some really
good values your parents are based what
do we call it based they're based yeah
they're grounded yeah yeah very I come
from a grounded family and also the
other part is how
um uh I don't want to say naughty but
that's a certainly but I wouldn't always
do in conforming when I was younger and
I spent a lot of time living up my grant
and like you said my grandma's very
she's calming she's older and she's
spiritual so that the answer and she
installed some good values again
spirituality intent Gordon's just again
understanding whether you when I say
Religion she was religious but it's not
necessarily religion it's just
spirituality and knowing oneself and
yeah so they always say know thyself
things like that this yeah
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats for one
second if they insult you I'm sorry but
I'm going to read them
um anyways like the video guys make sure
you subscribe to the channel and also we
have a Google form we're gonna do
meetups in London we're gonna have a
little party we're leaving on the 15th
for America for a couple weeks hopefully
I don't want to speak too soon
we're supposed to go to Dubai once and
it didn't work out but but hopefully
we're gonna go to America on the 15th so
we're hoping to do a meet up in London
um we're thinking of maybe even
um having guests from the show like sing
and rap and whatever because we've had
so many musicians on anyways okay the
truth will set you free
um thank you for the Super Chat need to
get rid of all the insta and social
media and go back to the heartless crew
days n19 ether 9 after elthrone big up
um Doug MPA as long as women
use a man's vulnerabilities and fears
against him in a fight it will never be
okay for a man to show his emotions men
have barriers in Conflict but women
don't ladies stop crushing your men
emotionally in a fight
um Adam Sutton you've hit on a great
quote this episode Pearl the feminine
way to do things is always assume to be
right 90 free-toe pie I'm not saying all
stupid
um okay please
are we uh oh wait let me refresh it
because that was from last show
uh
uh okay and then Lucas got a jet but
keep preaching Pearl um your mods are
legit
they need a raise yeah shout out dog MPA
they're everywhere actually they're on
all of our talents channels
um also guys we are looking for new
talents to sign at the network so if you
are interested in starting a YouTube
channel we literally do everything for
you so if you're interested in that
um message me just pearly things one
show me your content show me whatever
um our other talents have gotten I don't
know 50 000 Subs in like three four
months so you know we do know what we're
doing here when it comes to YouTube okay
so what do you guys think how do you
think social media has impacted dating
probably made it easier into respect
okay
I mean what it is is everyone's more
accessible the intent and you don't need
as much courage again if you go and
trying to chat someone in a supermarket
you've got uh yeah and certain things
are gonna you're not even gonna approach
them if you ain't looking right or
feeling right or smelling right you're
intend he's a bit on the internet you
could be sitting there and then you
probably ain't watch for example watch
for two days you can slide to someone's
dead
so it makes it easier and again it's a
numbers game you can probably slide in
20 people's DMS and if you play a
numbers game you might be gonna get one
or two replies in the inside you're
gonna be able to suck off the energy of
that yeah anyways before you have to you
intent you have to see them in person I
think people Miss meeting up in person
yeah that's what I'm going to say as
well yeah
I think you need to kind of have that
interaction and it's taking it away and
it's making it so much easier so people
don't need to so I think it's actually
it makes people more easy but I don't
think it's a good thing it's a bad thing
yeah people that these days just in
general like it all someone says
something earlier now it's thinking that
it's a good point because like in this
Society everything is more easy and it
didn't sound like it's all quick and
stuff like that but when they've made
things easier it doesn't necessarily
make them better or make it better yeah
yeah I think when I was saying something
about women not being able to vote
what struck me at that point there was
like simple you know sometimes simple
was the best simple but effective yeah
but simple and easier two different
things is that now this if it's easy yo
you get in your car but Sat Nav on so
then your brain ain't working before the
end time when I was driving you have to
know where to get somewhere or you get
your A to Z out co-pilot A to Z it is
answer your brain's thinking nowadays if
it's easy sat nav but the SAT nav's not
working
that's just making things easy same with
all these all these apps they're there
to design to make things easy but it
just means your brain is not going to be
working as efficiently so people can
edit their photos so much like it
literally look completely different that
happens with
not you guys
but a lot of girls that come on the show
because I'll see them in person and then
after like they might tag me in a story
or something and I'll like just check
out their page and I'm like who is that
like I just I just met her
and I'm like I'll see where the men are
coming from because
well I would say um from what you just
mentioned about the whole social media
it's got its ups and downs in it so like
personally it's a good thing yeah even
though we say it's a bad thing it is a
bad thing because keeping things how it
was back then everyone probably used
their brain more and probably will be
smarter as a nation and won't get
dragged into the social media so much
but social media has put lack for
yourself it's put your stuff out it's
put your things about people see you
more you're more interactive things are
happening to when it was back then there
weren't no YouTube there weren't on
social media weren't no so it has its up
and downs is that using it for business
right it's a business center right but
no one didn't realize that okay there's
an app we can make uh one where you come
on and stream them all and they're alive
and we're talking and we're getting
today amazing relationships there's
there's ups and downs to everything what
did you say I said it's amazing for the
business side like it's opened up so
many does collaborations like so many
does but for relationships I don't think
it's yeah I don't I don't think nothing
it creates like unrealistic expectations
especially with dating as well a lot of
people will compare situations that you
may see something online and someone
going to like hakistan or nice
restaurant and then why can't I go to
that restaurant and at least you know
you're creating like dramas over seeing
stuff in Carolina wanting to have like a
similar lives after that and loads of
people get into situations like and they
can't do that they can't take the girl
to a nice restaurant and sometimes maybe
they feel less of a way because they
can't do that at the time the people
probably haven't even eaten there
they've just gone yeah
literally I feel like the whole like the
Highlight social like social medias
makes people just want to like compare
to too much man too much comparison
pressure on us yeah I mean as men I
would say not so much women women could
just fling a picture up catfish the
thing
you gotta smiling and man is just happy
to like it and you feel good like as for
men I feel like the social media thing
we've got a you've got a punch kind of
high because girls are looking at level
say for instance social media is how it
works yeah so boom I've got a certain
amount of followers you might not have
that yeah that means now I'm more
popular than you so I'm more likely to
get this gallon than you because who I
am just doing status so now if we go
back to the real world I'm gonna see you
on the road
no we'll get to know you though who you
are yeah without social yeah you see how
your relationship probably blossomed me
for more away from the social media but
because we're all sucked into the media
and the way it's programmed you're gonna
go for the glamor team you're going to
go for the one who's doing but more than
the other that's just how we are
personally I think a lot of men don't
allow these like sliding themes like you
said before a lot of guys sliding themes
a lot of guys that haven't really got
the courage nowadays not that I didn't
go to college but they don't they won't
move to go on the face-to-face thing you
know what I'm saying you see if you see
a girl a lot if they're in that scenes
or whatever you see a guy like approach
the girl and chapter and try and get
things done that's what I see but a lot
of girls want that dog a lot of girls
want that I think it's because like
social media has made women delusional
like by and large you know I'm not
saying every woman but I'm saying by and
large Like It's Made Girls delusional
because we get attention from the top 20
percent of men so then women like as
women we think we're in the top 20 of
women because women got more options as
well right right and so it's like they
call they call it like hoflation where
it's like it's like men have to work
twice like 20 times as hard as their
grandmother to get a woman that's like
10 times as work like worse because
women today don't have the traditional
things that like women are typically
valued for and you know you because then
and then I used to think about this
because like I feel like as a girl your
gut reaction is like well not all women
are like that like I didn't do that but
when you think about it no women is safe
for men because of social media because
like as long as a girl has social media
like top tier men will always have
access to her and it's not to say that
she'll say yes but it's like in a way no
girl is really safe because you can
still be brainwashed by the modern
mindset and that's what you're cool yeah
and there's even there's like a
prominent conservative that just got
divorced and his wife divorced him and
this was like on paper like the picture
perfect girl like she had two parent
home all the things that you would want
and she's still divorcing him and so
it's like even if a guy picks right he
could still end up wear with a broken
family
but do you think here that bad by the
social media like getting involved and
making life you know the technology the
internet's got more better things have
got better in life but worse for the
ones what need that help you know what
I'm saying because like I'm a person who
who's not on the social media but I'm I
like this girl and I'm a really nice guy
but she's just not into me because I'm
not that guy who's doing that that's not
fair on the guy is it but I mean she's
not for you but then but that's what I'm
saying you think that way as well but
then at the same time I didn't even get
opportunity right right now that's what
I'm saying and this is
but that's what I'm saying if you're not
in the game yeah
sorry if you're not in the game then
it's a myth for you bro yeah you
understand like certain man go out
clubbing with like for me personally I I
tend to not go at clubbing that much
anymore because I know what time it is
do you understand but certain mom will
have to say to me come else
and then man get there same [__] again
do not understand I'm not trying to pull
girls and [__] like that but they will
tend to roll up because oh it's that guy
you get me when really the guy you're
looking for is right here this brother
right here he's got no but guys that
guy's moving though nice guys move into
the average female though that's the
problem
is because like before a beautiful girl
in in a town like she's gonna date the
guys in her town and like people kind of
looks Max accordingly where it's like
now a guy can have a girl in three
different cities he's dating three women
yeah and that's taking that's taking
away women from the other guys that
would date them like in their cities so
it's like there's more competition for
men
yeah and the women like and doesn't you
know it doesn't make me happy to say
this you know I I wish you know as a
group we did better but like as a group
like we offer less than ever before what
was women yeah as well like we how could
we argue if men value Purity and youth
and we're older when we get married and
the the number of women with more than
10 sexual partners before marriage is
like increasing it's like I can't I
can't say we bring more like that has to
be less it's very true as a group you
know I mean people people will say oh
I'm too negative but I'm just like well
I'm just analyzing what it is
but I feel like they're portraying an
image in terms of like sexuality
portraying it so much like you know
whole surgery a whole bbo movement all
that stuff as well for a lot of girls
you know feel they need to
um because this girl's got a nice bomb
need to take you know get surgery and
hearts himself and that's going to get
them the guy they've always wanted to
get and then it's like it goes you know
go around in circles as well I thought
it's actually even like I like that
really yeah it looks good it looks good
it's a bit practical though
I think I think a lot of guys do like
that as well but it's not gonna a guy
will still cheat regardless so I'm
saying I was still [__] another girl
regardless I'm saying you if you look
good because like I said before without
building relationships that's all about
character and your personality is going
to carry you through and if you just
like image that okay you look good I've
run through you now what's next you know
I'm saying [__] you know what I think
about what happens after the girl has a
child
like what happens is does the butt fall
like your body changes
and I think about that with boob jobs
too because I'm like when you're giving
the kid like milk like yeah
I don't I heard like even nipple
piercings like does weird [__] to uh but
it's going against Natural stuff that's
the thing about it again
I don't know what's gonna happen though
family because I know a certain guy
who's skinny and got pregnant and put on
weight and they look buffed yeah yeah
that's right I'm not sure though he's
saying BPL that's what I'm saying I'm
saying that she was mentioning about how
does your tits do this and your bum drop
I'm saying nothing bum goes up and
titties bounce you understand because
I've seen it and I'm talking personally
I've seen women because they're like
glowing you understand certain guy look
fresh when they were skinny beginner
and then now you've gained the natural
weight like mama say Natural Woman and
she's got bum bum breasts and she looks
even better after having a child patient
and that's again down to patients
I know like years ago when
um when I was in school you said similar
to pretty skilled lay it down turn that
down
that happens
again life takes his toe yeah
a lot of guys who rate them in secondary
school whatever and then it gets to
their head and then they stop working on
herself they just she just let me sort
of go with everyone but yeah they said
things they're subject to change so the
incense is true what you're saying man
well that's the majority I forgot what
you guys's obesity they y'all talk so
much [__] about America being so fat and
then I looked at you guys obesity
England's stats and I was like you guys
are not much better
it's like there's fat people over there
yeah what do you expect though there are
more recent things
no man listen if I was living in a hot
country I won't eat that much nah it's
not that man I think that you said don't
make me eat when I go on holidays that's
because you live in a cold country
though but if you lived in a hot country
your body would be used to it so you
probably would eat as well same thing
yeah you would no yeah
60 of women are overweight or obese
where it's 70 in the UK or so I are in
the US so I was like yeah the UK's
thinner but you know it's not five years
ten years ago one though really that was
always just in 10 years how was it 10
years ago now the world is evening up
everything is living up all right and
Stephanie Western countries it's evening
up you know it's all this body
positivity stuff man they like it's all
lies to be honest with you like I think
a lot of social media will trade like oh
sorry rap for you to be a certain way
and accept you you uh you'll wait for
who you are and that but I thought a lot
of people it's not true I feel like if
you're unhealthy unhealthy you know what
I'm saying I thought people are scared
naturally told tell their friend that
you know the Virgin whoever look like
you need to lose weight because it's
like Soul SEPTA nowadays to be like you
know if you're 300 pounds and you're
that is cool like you can be in a cover
magazine be 300 pounds and
you're unhealthy like and I feel like
people should try and help that person
but it's not cool to do that because
it's like they want to portray that
everyone to be the same yeah I'm saying
yeah yeah people escape because you're
gonna get cancer if you say what you're
fat lose weight like
this some sort of person I'm saying to
you but really and truthfully I feel
like this whole body positivity thing
has gone way too far Man Too Far yeah
actually because I was thinking about
this you know if I go to an NBA game all
right you guys football here you guys
but you guys
you guys don't go there and expect to
see average soccer
right you don't go there like you'd be
pissed if you go to this if this yeah I
keep saying soccer this football game
and you just get there and there's
average football players why then are we
putting average and below average
looking women on the cover of magazines
and modeling I'm supposed to be inspired
because when I see it I'm supposed to
last because I want to look like her
you want to create acceptance for
everyone but it's not like that it's not
like that all right and this is the
problem is though when it comes to
people trying to even get in shape and
be healthy and that people got unlisted
expectations because of what it is it's
like like you said before about being
fast and instant people expect to get
results instantly because that's what
people are preaching six weeks 12 weeks
to lose weight you'll do this take a
magic pool and people are nothing like
do not [__] this I wanna just
do this surgery or do the stairways and
get a result faster but yet they've they
haven't faced other things they haven't
built themselves a character I don't
discipline they haven't built themselves
up the mindsets work and stuff like that
so once they've that kind of cheek hold
it away they've got all these issues and
stuff like that so I think really and
truthfully like this whole receptive
thing is not like it's not like it is
you probably see the stats probably like
one percent of people in really good
shape the rest ain't you know I'm saying
true that's that's what it is I think
it's mean actually I think it's me and I
think the people that push it are liars
I think they're big liars and I think
they're the mean ones they think I'm the
mean mean one because you know I call
women whales sometimes only if they are
and
you guys are saying you look beautiful
your queen you're this I'm like you guys
are just big Liars well you know what
I've got I've got friends here I think
my friends that they'll say like they
get more they don't get attention and
when they're all that out of shape
they're getting more attention guys need
to go something like that because they
think it's going to be easier yeah
because it goes big she's not getting
yeah she's gonna move but you know what
again it comes down to society trying to
make things equal but again things not
equal and they're trying to make it yeah
but that big girls and small girls
modeling and stuff make it equal and
stuff like then everything's just
equalized but again things are not equal
100 things are generally not fair yeah
and that people said people are not
being honest I mean it's I wouldn't say
it's right to call someone a well but
again it's not necessarily you're right
you're right honestly I should apologize
to the whales in the sea we're comparing
a beautiful Majestic creature to a fat
chicks
again it's not necessarily what you said
was how you say it yeah but yeah it's
being a bit I say very nicely
I'll say yeah my point of that that the
whole oversized thing for me this girl
who's just big boned they're not
actually fat women do you understand
that they look good the same do you
understand yeah but I think but I feel
they believe that too much though we do
we are both on like no your bones are
not like next skeleton bones I mean just
look at a go and tell the sizes bones in
the same as her bones you don't
understand straight away I feel
a lot of people excuse me I'm not trying
to give excuses
I agree with what you're saying but I've
got a friend who lacks fat girl yeah
yeah
it's your preference it's not a question
how much does he make two that your
friend that likes fetching I don't know
what what he makes I don't watch men's
money land I don't watch no one's money
I don't watch no one's pieces
because that's what they say like a fat
chicken on a guy's arms is just like one
way to show that he's broke is it yeah
the men with money status and Power
is because once again we've gone back
into the Media Chat do you feel me like
if we go away from that there's galacto
eat food fam just like random yeah I
mean some girl put on weight more than
others
and yeah I agree with you to where
you're saying this a fitness thing and
they're not pushing us off they're being
lazy getting diabetes all these bad
things happen to you when you put on on
your overweight and your old beast but
there's some girl there who can still do
the sprinting thing they're quite big
and some girl yeah
skinny girl who has dead in bed and
you've got a big thing who [__] you good
do you understand
this is the programming that's what it
is that is a program this is it because
they convince you that if the girls
don't need to do anything they have the
girl as big she has something else but
this is what I'm saying yeah this is
what they can they convince the men like
so the the fat chicks can compete that
they're like nicer they're better but
it's like you know I think about it if
you're sleeping with a fat girl like
she's not gonna have the same like
energy
that's what I'm saying I'm telling you
no you said a good point which is Health
yeah healthy I agree with that that is a
great Point yeah yeah
I agree with one thing you know big
people small you can have good
characters and ugly some people are
going to be bigger than others but
health is it's the first thing yeah yeah
yeah you know my dad I was dating a
bigger guy once you know and my dad was
like you got to cut that off and I was
like why dad and he's like yeah because
of his weight and I was like well isn't
that a bit mean and he said no otherwise
you're gonna have to take care of him
someday and I had to really think about
it I was like from a practical point of
view if you date a bigger person you are
gonna have to take care of them someday
yeah you can see where you get your
is he going no right so there you go
then so we're not getting sucked in but
that's no no no no but no but that's
different though it's the same thing
he's overweight he's obese a lot of
relationships people putting weight you
know that's what I'm trying to say to
you so we're going back on ourselves we
have put on weight though and I've
stayed with him through it yes and you
lost it because you wanted to work it
off so there's a way of doing things
though there is there is
Big born girls
a lot of girls that are big boned feel
that because they're big bone they can't
lose the weight so they won't put in the
actual effort see what you're saying
with the whole effort and losing weight
I agree with you 100 percent there
shouldn't be overbees settings you feel
me because that means you're lazy you're
just you've let food overtake your body
that's a Madness do you understand but
when your bones are big like you're
grown that way and you're built like
that that's the support of life I think
it's programming and I think it's it's a
way of women telling men you can't have
standards because every time a man has a
standard women just really break it down
to be honest so it's like if a man wants
a woman that's not a [__] then they're
[__] shaming if a man wants a woman
that's skinny then they're fat shaming
and I think the big boned thing is just
a way for fat chicks to compete because
they could say oh I'm still healthy I'm
just big boned but if we look at the
pictures look at that picture of a beach
of of from 100 years ago there was no
big boned women what did they magically
get born but they went no we got fatter
all right cool boom I can break down a
big big example back in the day there
was no girls like not trying to put it
as a racing but kind of slightly is in
my time white girls never had bums none
of them
certain colors
but now in this day and age Marilyn
Monroe but she was like the picture of
you
know the Blue Moon Yeah but he said none
no back in the day there was none in my
end solution it was done out there was
no girls with backs I'll be real with
you I was I've been there on the streets
know what time it is now in this day and
age
it's popular to have asked you know what
I'm saying what happened you know it is
the big thing as well slim thick and fat
thick as well a lot of girls that are
big they think they actually are thick
but they're not fit
I know what you're talking about but the
point I'm trying to make is back then it
wasn't in there was nothing there bro do
you understand this is so many like body
Trends now yeah but it's coming like as
the generations are going on everyone's
developing even the younger kids are
looking older you see it people are
looking different now they we can't go I
can't go down the road my daughter's 14
bro I can't go down the road and I ain't
gonna have mango and I'm like what yeah
but that's because the development now
everything's changing bro we see it
there's young girls that look like big
girl is is the difference between that
and maybe we're actually not being
healthy which is actually dangerous yeah
yeah I know I heard that yes I'm just
saying I'll show you Michael walk one
with the the setup yeah it's changed
yeah do you understand so when I'm
talking about big boned and all these
stuff so things went in back then
obviously man will go for a go of a big
body because it's in people like to see
big bums it's all unsocial you see a
girl with big bum shaking you're like
that you know what I'm saying when we
look at the models in Hollywood like I
don't really see a huge change in in the
picture of like Beauty and Society like
maybe a little bit too much like plastic
starts slightly but like when you look
at like the the most beautiful women
like from 50 years ago to now they're
like no matter what race like they're
always thin and even in Hollywood now
the most successful sought after
beautiful women are always thin they
might be thin with a book it must be the
films I watched in because when I was
watching stuff enough about galad body
you understand they got bum bum rest all
of that that's probably natural you
reckon it's a natural thing it's a black
thing then you're saying yes genetics
might be them because now these days
there's a lot of white girls different
race with bumps but that's not not true
I don't think that's natural some some
girls yeah
they're working out it's not natural
they have to do squats and stuff like
that there's a lot there yeah I hear you
still it could be genetics we don't know
in it we're just gonna go for what we we
think but okay yeah guys I got in
trouble on Twitter this week you know
it's crazy I'm so reasonable and it's
like
people on Twitter they just get so mad
at me for my opinions which is weird
because I think they're all right so
yeah so I had this tweet to them
I said I believe that married people
should work through infidelity at all
costs sticking out for sticking out
something for children is not a bad
thing
I totally agree um
is that does anyone disagree with me
um what did you mean by that though can
you explain it a bit more you know I
think a lot of times
well I do think if a woman sheets it's
worse than if a guy cheats why yeah
because I think that when men can screw
a girl and not have feelings where I
don't think women can like naturally
just have sex with a guy well like at
all no exceptions or obviously there's
going to be there's exceptions but like
just by and large I think men can like
easier separate sex from emotion I think
men and women are different so I think
if a woman cheats she's more likely to
be emotionally involved than if a guy
cheats
so so I do think it's worse if a girl
cheats but I think both are wrong I
don't think I'm not pro cheating they
misconstrue that opinion of mine but
like they all say I'm approaching I'm
not pro cheating but I think when you
have kids it's not about you anymore
it's now about your children so I think
we're in a society that says my feelings
should come first but I think once you
have kids the kids feelings should come
first I agree so I think if you can stay
together for your children you should
and I believe this you know this is a
little controversial I believe a man or
woman if you you can stick it out for
the kids I I think you should I agree
with you
well even though I don't do you have to
be together to stick out for the kids
though that's a bad move that's a bad
move no no I'm saying in terms of lack
these are agreed to do no no but I agree
with it I'm gonna let you say you're
saying but I'm thinking like do you have
like you can be mature about things and
you can both want the best for your kids
but both have different relationships
for other people you have you got to be
together like that though yeah no I can
work out that if you're both mature
about and you prioritize you know the
kids as you know so you're talking about
experience
I'll tell you why I think I'll tell you
why I think this right so the the single
so again single single mother stats
right 63 of all youth suicides from
single mother homes 70 of all teen
pregnancies 71 of all adolescent
chemical substance abuse 80 of all
prison inmates ninety percent of all
homeless and runaway children
um they're five times more likely to
commit suicide nine times more likely to
drop out of high school ten times more
likely to abuse chemical substances 14
more like times more likely to commit
great 29 sometimes more likely to end up
in prison and 32 more times more likely
to run away from home on top of that if
you're bringing in other people in and
out of the home like that that's a way
that the kids can be abused right and
like that's what you're putting your
kids at risk like the most likely person
to abuse a child or like touch a kid is
like someone that they bring into the
home so it's like to me if you can avoid
that and just keep the parents together
why would you yeah well if you have a
guy and he cheated and you multiple
times you still want to try to stick it
yeah I'm gonna try to stick it out
because I believe in marriage I believe
in vows and like people people always
give me Flack for this because they
think I'm like a picky I don't want to
be cheating I don't think that's good I
don't think it's good for a marriage to
like bring other people outside of the
marriage and do a relationship but my
point is like it it why like it's
selfish of me as a mother like as a
mother you should want what's best for
your kids above all else so it's selfish
for me to say well because of my
feelings I'm going to now put my kids in
a position where they can be abused I'm
now going to put my kids at a position
where they are more likely to commit
suicide I can put my kids in a position
where they're more likely to drop out of
high school do drop like every
statistical disadvantage you can put
your kid out you're putting them at in a
single mother home and on top of that
like with the way the court system are
is today like fathers are lucky if they
get six days a month so now you're going
from a position where every day the kid
sees its dad to seeing it six days a
month and I I think it's like this is
all of the problems in society are from
this one choice of women leaving and I
and I think like yeah so if a guy
cheated on me I'd be like damn my time
four times multiple times and my goal
would always be to work it out yeah my
goal is always I'm not saying 100 of the
time but yeah go ahead um so cool I'm
gonna hit the no on its head to your car
I hear what you're saying and keeping
the dad around and the kids know their
father and being a family is the way
forward but you're forgetting that if
this guy is abusive and he beats up the
girl and beats her all the time in front
of the kids you know that's not good for
the child that child will grow up to
beating other females or even beating up
his own siblings do you know what I mean
there is always gonna be a problem in
that situation I'm gonna give you I'm
going to give you a little red pill
right here okay so like first of all um
real abuse yeah I agree like I agree
real abuse like yes they should not be
together I do believe in separation for
abuse you don't want that however the
issue today is women are paid to claim
abuse
so a lot of women that tell you they
were abused go ask them did you file a
police report and did you take him to
court and the majority of the time the
answer is no so why are we going to
believe someone that has no evidence of
of a crime and and that's that's my
thing and so what they do is they go to
Family Court and so they can get child
support and so they can get like money
from the government they get it from
literally
um saying that he's abused so a lot of
girls that say they're abused they
weren't actually abused and and the
other thing is
um
there's so many issues in the justice
system so it's real abuse yeah but I
don't think it's nearly as common as
women say because the other thing is
anyone that's worked or worked with
couples that like were like in domestic
abuse situations more I can't remember
what percent of the time but it's like
40 of the time something like that women
hit too yeah and how many times does a
woman emotionally abuse a man which I
think emotional abuse is worse than
physical abuse and so then a guy one day
snaps and then she says oh he hit me
I mean that was a good point and what
you said originally was
um she you didn't actually say abuse but
you didn't say yeah took it to the next
side yeah so but I mean what you said
there what you both said if it's really
abusive probably they shouldn't stick
around the internet for the child agreed
it but definitely if um man cheats and
even if a woman cheats for the sake of
the kids I think it's definitely worth
sticking out and working out even if
multiple times there's other ways to go
around it and fix the problem you can
send them try and work out and maybe
with men men are gonna sleep around oh
God this is a trait of men they're
always gonna it's like sleep around
because this is just men it's again it's
natural
and it is what it is and again it's not
there's no longer right to it but if you
know this and understand it then you
accept it you're probably not gonna
like end up in that kind of emotional
state because a lot of times what Paul
said is
women are being emotional making but
would you get another decision so and
then once their decision is in a
restaurant but they're not thinking
about the kids and dancing they're
putting their kids in a real awkward
position via the statistics watch Pearl
just said so really and truly you may as
well stick it out Ian's end because you
want the best for your kids or you pay
me one of the best speakers and other
flips out of this is so is that let's
just say
couples together they've got kids guys
cheated
the woman gets rid of him he cheats a
couple times let's just says he cheats
three four times yeah it would later
gets rid of him
what's to say the next man isn't going
to cheat it's true so you now you've got
rid of your your original baby forever
who you understand ultimately he's
invested in the family this is the
intent so you've got rid of him excuse
me and then you've got another man on
yeah and again men
but this is just a trait of minions and
so you're going to get someone else in
and then they're likely to do the same
thing so what you're going to do with
nature you're gonna again it just makes
up and a lot of times women get spiteful
in relationships where they don't let
the dad like see the kids and like the
other thing that they don't talk about
is there's a whole generation of like
men and women that have been lied to by
their moms by saying their dad's a
deadbeat when he's really not a deadbeat
when really like like they've just I
mean we saw it happen to Kanye before
our eyes right he loved his mom and and
freaking um she moved so the dad
couldn't see the kid and that was that
was why he wasn't in the lot in in their
life so I just think a lot of I know
they always get on me for like living
things on women but it's like when we
got power this is what we did it's a
it's a it's a vicious circle that what
that we're in obviously because when I
deep it like I hear both sides as well
like yeah that's a hundred percent
should be in in the kids lives you know
I mean if you bring a child into the
world you expect both parents to play
their parts do you know what I mean but
if this person is abusive it's not good
for the child because the kid will grow
up knowing that okay this is what used
to happen to my mom or my dad you know I
mean I'm vice versa what what percent of
relationships are abusive a lot more
than that's what's that show 100 yeah I
think it's a lot more and you've got a
different rating on there no I'm saying
like I I think it's a lot more if I if I
had to guess I think it's a lot more
that women abuse men than men Abused
Women because when they looked at
one-sided abuse so again most abuse is
two-sided meaning they're both they're
beating the [__] out of each other so at
that point like you can't say he was
abusive you both were abusive in
different ways right but it but it
doesn't like count
right but the thing is they looked at
one-sided abuse meaning one party's
hitting the other and the other's not
hitting back and like let's just call
spay to Spade women do that to men more
than men do it to women and the men who
abuse is again sometimes worse than the
physical mental abuses the little
teasing or the wind ups yeah you can't
do this so you can't do no you know a
real man just you're around sexual
things
and then that day over a long period of
time it's probably worse as I said
sticks and stones but I still think a
man and a female can make it work I
think it's both are mature and they're
both you know all around it I agree with
you I don't think I don't think like all
women are bad I don't I don't think like
but the the issue is that when you pick
a girl like she it's always if like it's
up to her she has all the power in the
relationship because at the end of the
day like I talked to a divorce attorney
about this and he said I'm not afraid of
marriage I'm afraid of children because
once you have kids with a girl the kids
aren't yours they're hers wow that's so
that's it that's so so so true my kids
are mine
until a situations
and some and some women aren't going to
do that they're going to let you like
they're gonna watch you in the kid's
life but like we all change when we're
spiteful like I think everyone could say
at some point you've probably done
something when you're angry you're not
proud yeah I certainly have and so it's
like but when you have a system that
likes that when two people are at their
maddest one has all the power like
that's just a bad system so and it puts
like it has women make like worse
decisions than maybe they normally would
if they didn't have this much power
and again it comes down to them emotions
women being just about to say that you
say manage emotions go back to what you
said before that's it just come back
down to that being the intending
situation woman's got the children in
there that's emotionally irrational and
it's it's just yeah it's a spiral
downward spiral so I'm running the chat
is saying lesbian couples have the
highest domestic violence cases really
makes sense two women make sense so
basically women one is going to try and
be a man and that's how yeah that's how
it goes yeah you couldn't you could see
things you've sent but how do you how do
you manage that then how does like on a
woman level yeah like women I'm chatting
to the girl them now how do you manage
your behavior because it's always Mana
for do this
what about the women and what do you do
to manage your behavior then because
there's a system for men what they must
do we can't cry around girl oh you look
too weak you're weakling okay cool what
is the next thing then what does the
girls do
we're naturally emotional so it is just
being emotional yeah but that's it being
emotional and then being evil and
spiteful and dealing with man wrong and
using the system
what's the next thing then like after
another sorting out your issues because
you're basically saying men are getting
[__] over 24 7. what's the system to
to stop that girl's then why why I mean
I mean I think the only way to stop it
is to change the laws but again it goes
back to the same problem how do you
change the lives of the politicians have
no incentive to do so you know I mean I
I think like on an individual level as
women like we can we can actually give
good advice to the younger generation
like get married younger have kids
younger you know um don't sleep around
like actually give good advice but if
I'm being realistic again I don't think
the women the younger women are going to
be less promiscuous I just don't think
it's gonna happen
[Music]
yeah I mean you could tell me you're
you're 21 yeah it's out there listen 22
Yeah 21 so yeah I doubt they'll listen I
doubt they listen I don't think they
would either I think
in their heads
their way of life is empowering but it's
actually not it's the way that they've
been taught it it's actually the
opposite same thing with the only fans
thing you think is empowering but it's
not and it's really sad to be honest
like I don't think women are like I
don't think women are going to be happy
at the end of it not not anymore no and
it's like we're seeing a higher rate of
women on antidepressants than ever
before like it's it's stupidly high and
and so I just I think a lot like the
whole generation of women we've been
lied to and it's like you know we wake
up wanting to get married but none of us
really have the skills to be married
yeah
it's a fairy tale again women are like
giving that fairy tale from the Barbie
and Ken and from the beginning that's
been taught to us by women as well and
and men are too to be fair like our men
really taught how to lead in a
relationship
no like they're not even told they're
allowed to in society when men are
supposed to lead and women want men that
lead and when women want men that are
masculine but it's like are men told and
empowered to do that no so matter like
so it's almost like we have men and
women neither of us have the skills to
be together and we're trying to switch
what's always worked like it is always
worth men being the head of the
household and now we're trying something
different is it working but again all
this is on purpose is that when you said
how can you fix this it's just that
crime there's ways of going around and
try like eradicating crime and or
listening listen or eradicating it but
listen it what crime makes the
government and makes the world a lot of
money so these people they don't
actually want to stop it it's good for
them it's good business just like this
whole thing what's going on now with men
being less masculine than women being
more masculine it's good business for
them whatever their reasons are behind
it like it's on purpose they're not
doing these things by chance this has
been happening gradually over years
and because they've got a there's a plan
at hand
yeah which is unfolding and then I
thought I thought that the government
wants control over people that's why
they do loads of things like you think
about the pharmaceutical industry yeah
it's a multi-billion pound industry you
know I'm saying to you people are
antidepressants yeah for a reason you
know what I mean and I know even I know
family members of antidepressants and I
know they've gained weight I know
they've if they're numb to their
emotions they don't feel anything and
it's like when they come off the
medication for like one day or two days
they just have like mad panic attacks
they go go crazy and it's just like this
whole sort of control trying to control
an individual you know I think that's a
big thing as well and the crazy thing is
they give you drugs before they they
switch your food
exactly yeah so so like someone will
come in and say I'm depressed yeah well
of course you're depressed you're
overweight and so if you're putting if
you're putting toxins into your body
you're going to be in your sleep
schedule is [__] yeah and you're not
gonna be happy and they'll put you on
drugs that you have to be on for the
rest of your life before they change
they encourage you to change your
lifestyle but again that's right like
you said it's to do with money and it's
business is greed that you can go to the
doctors they don't even know what's
wrong with you and they're going to give
you some kind of medication but then if
you go back yes back back all these
things were natural they were natural
remedies to heal you and plus most of
these black drugs what they've made
they've made them off Natural Things
anyway and then they've seen something
natural and made it unnatural it's got a
percentage of it so it still kind of
half works but it's unnatural and it's
money where most these natural drugs are
free yeah they don't want to if there's
money in control and business and I
think they don't want like men and women
to get along I don't think they want us
together I don't know why but I think
there's some there's some agenda that's
like literally trying to break down the
family
they can control I answered from the
feminist movement it's control they want
to control people and control money and
make money and get people away from
spirituality so breaking down the family
the intentions they pay you to do it I
mean I don't know a lot of times the
laws in the US and the UK are like
semi-similar but it's like if you pay a
girl to divorce her husband
she's not feeling it she's gonna do it
like if you pay anyone to do as we said
earlier in the show you know if you pay
even even you guys like you don't seem
like you you're out there you know doing
anything crazy right but you might if
they pay you to like if they say Hey you
get 500 bucks if you go steal an iPhone
from Apple you might not like that's the
principle it's true
I like to think I wouldn't right but
over 10 years 20 years 30 years if I
watch everybody stealing from Apple
getting 500 every time they say I might
start to you know I'm human I might
start to think about it I think his mind
over my mouth didn't you hear about that
same with the girls were going out to
Dubai and getting [__] in their mouth
yeah but I know that happens a lot
though yeah because they're like yeah
money money is the evil fam obviously we
will know but we will need it you get me
and it's peer pressure and and
um just having that that brain in your
head I don't think it's peer pressure it
must be because you are broke not using
this in you
but this is what I think whenever a girl
makes a poor choice we always give her a
bailout yeah and I'm bailing her out
right yeah
instead of herself yeah let me not bail
you out then no but I did that because
you wanted to then yeah right
you did that because you won but you
know okay if I do if a dude like shoot
if I do if a dude shoots somebody or
does something super aggressive which is
like the male like equivalent right like
if a woman does something like is that
something only women really can do where
men like they're more aggressive so like
extreme masculinity is like committing a
crime so if a man commits a crime you
don't really say oh it was peer pressure
you say now you're in jail yeah you get
your ass to print yeah yeah yeah it's
true well you know a lot of girls
actually want to be like housewives in
that as well so maybe they want to laugh
some girls want to like literally just
want a man to take care of them and they
just want to be at home and sometimes
maybe do certain things like on the
secret which is fine if you have the
skills to do that but that's the problem
is like most girls don't have the skills
to be a housewife they're saying make me
a house right but they're average
looking they've never they've never even
gotten like like they've never even
cooked for a whole family they've never
like think about like one percent of
girls I mean you guys are out there
dating like what percent of girls really
know how to like cook like what percent
of girls really know how like have their
own recipes that they bake from scratch
like what percent of women are are
qualified to be Housewives only and and
the stats will tell you only 20 of women
get to be Housewives which is reversed
from like 100 years ago where it's like
80 of women were Housewives couldn't
that also be like um the financial side
regarding men they just can't afford to
have a housewife they need their wife to
go in well well there's two sides to
this like one side is that when women
entered the workforce like it made wages
go down because if you've doubled the
amount of people like you you can pay
them less so that's one part of it and
the second part is that women want to
live in the city they want a certain
lifestyle how much does it really cost
when you think about it how much does it
really cost to rent an apartment never
buy new like just food clothes shelter
to a month
but not in London so like outside of
it's cheaper but I don't know how much
cheaper but it's a lot cheaper so I I
know there's a girl in in Florida who
lives off of ten thousand dollars a year
for 10 kids
and I'll tell you how she does yeah it's
not nuts yeah I'll tell you how she does
it she lives up like so her husband
drives like two hours to the city they
live in the country she Farms all her
own food so they don't really have high
food costs they um cook all their stuff
from scratch they um only do
hand-me-downs or they sew the clothes
but what percent like who who knows how
to do that nobody that's all that's
crazy
that's good so she says I'm so busy like
I don't have any time to even think
about partying think about that she
homeschools her kids like when you think
about it you can do that but most girls
I don't want to yeah I mean I don't
really I'm just being honest I don't
really want to learn to sew you know I'm
just I'm just you know and I'm not
saying everybody has to but like we act
like there's no other options but there
are you could do that and she her
husband's gone a lot but you know her
kids get their kids get to see their mom
24 7.
[Music]
because that's what women can't really
do good at nurturing that mother in the
Comfort Inns and yes and I and I think
men work harder when they know their
families like relying on them
yeah because that's what men want to do
we've got that innately with the enzyme
we want to provide because again it's
the Natural Instincts of a man to you
and then want to protect and want to
provide the intent yes yeah that's it's
a standard you're not really looking for
a woman with lots of money whereas women
are looking for men with lots of money
but as a man you're not really looking
for that you're looking you want a nice
woman basically I think that's our
generation to our family yeah I was
going to say that as well because like
definitely the youngest don't give a
[__] yeah you understand about whatever
what you girls do
might not need no woman to defend for
man or be in the house and look after
man yeah Mama just told you do you and
cut through make their own peas yeah
like man that's what I'm saying it's the
it's the generation and it's the section
of people I my circle every man's got
done every man's up every man's doing
their thing every man's on point because
every man knows that it's not about
trying to fend off of your gallery or
nothing like that and there's my name
out there who don't like this generation
now who probably don't give two [__]
about if their girl's pregnant or not
like I will just get on with life in it
don't need her still gonna not check my
you bro I'm gonna still trap still gonna
do my thing so this is why when Bush was
just saying about how he would look at
things like that and good on the woman
who's doing that I hear it but the
generation now are not on it
so you're saying the men are like
leaving but men are not doing nothing so
I'll tell you but whose fault is that do
you okay is this true men will do
anything for sex
is it true or false no no no no no no
it's definitely truth in there 100 okay
yeah okay okay you okay so you don't
think okay if women require marriage to
get sex tomorrow you don't think men
would marry them yeah of course okay
like you have no other options okay okay
so so if if if men will do anything for
sex and they're still getting sex even
though they had they have like their TR
you said I don't know that doesn't sound
like a good thing I don't know what
you're stopping me you said traffic oh
no the the grinding working oh okay well
you said he's like getting the girl
pregnant and not caring being there for
this right so right so whose fault is
that it's the women for picking them
because we're in control of sex it's so
it's so true pickled baby dads wisely I
can't say it I can't say it I can't say
it more like I can't make it clear like
men are always gonna like men are always
good if you if you throw if you throw
meat in front of a tiger they're gonna
bite you know like men are always gonna
try to screw you like it's in the women
are in control of who they and even more
so women are not that abortion's legal
we're 100 we're we're 100 in control of
who's born so we're 100 in control of
who gets born so there's really no
excuse for for picking uh a bad you know
father of your kids once again I'm not
defending you women yeah but I think you
know I'm gonna say so men are smart you
know don't get this thing Twisted we're
not all stupid we're not dumb when you
said you you picked the right woman I
mean pick the right guy in your in the
time of picking the right guys or in the
relationships you've had over the years
not everyone's been correct to it but
it's not for you to blame
how much relationships
yeah okay only one person probably to
talk to them about it but there's other
women I'm a relationships you've been in
well but here's here's the thing here's
the thing here's the thing
because it's gonna make me answer the
question no no but this is the thing
like I think that you can how do you say
it you can
make a mistake once but you don't have
to have a kid with them yeah yeah so so
it's like if you're in a like you know
have I ever dated someone I wish I
didn't date yeah yeah and I I absolutely
have but it's like it's my choice if I
had a child with him yeah that's
different I thought he was on about just
dating in general guys and I'll give you
I'll give you one maybe two L's but like
it's like we we start to get like five
six seven eight eight L's and it's just
like you didn't learn anything men are
smart like I said back to what I was
trying to say men are smart don't ever
get this thing twisted if I want you to
think what I want you to think you will
think that you understand the same as
women men and women we we have our ways
of how to brainwash people do you
understand so if you're with a guy who's
technical nosy stuff it won't be hard
for man to baffle you and you will make
that mistake and pick the wrong guy and
you will get [__] out in their hair
and then whatever and it will just be
the same thing because Mama's baffling
you do you understand this certain girls
but I think it's just like going out of
your league again you're welcome yeah
yeah
the guys you're sleeping with don't want
you you're probably batting too high you
record yeah yeah it might be time to
battle they just want one thing for me
yeah like you know even even you know
the top 10 20 of men they still pick a
girl at some point so it's like if the
guys you're sleeping with aren't staying
you're probably batting a little too
high wow the men they know this if they
if they go approach a girl and she
rejects them they say all right I'll try
a little uglier
wow but the women no but we sleep with
the guys
come on let's just you know if you had
zero success with if you okay if you
approach ten tens and all of them
rejected you you might try nines and now
you approach ten nines and they 100 are
50 whatever I don't know I don't
approach so I don't know what's a good
number to get get a gauge then you
approach 58s and they all reject all
right I'll try so like I mean come on
like let's just call it space I'm
getting rejected by tens nines eight the
series he's this something that I'm
doing this not right obviously I need to
work on myself I need to do right I need
to do that level up in a certain way
right but that's that's how men think so
if you're if you're not getting the
girls you want you level up but
don't like what's women's
self-improvement genuinely meditation
yeah yeah like gym like whatever you
want to call it yeah we're trying to eat
all of that like it what especially
internal like what internal
self-improvement do women really do
that's like real it's not personality
that's what it is if you ain't got a
good personality and you don't bubble
with me
personality is more important than that
than anything right but right
but men will keep approaching to learn
how to like talk to women like I hear
guys like oh I didn't get any play when
I was younger and then I just approached
or I learned like what women liked
whatever but it's like women there's no
real want to improve for man because
like we know yeah we don't have to yeah
but that's what he's approaches like we
don't think in our heads like oh let me
go what do I have to upgrade yeah yeah
and I'm saying your personality will
shine through and that's what I would
prefer how do you improve your
personality by being a nice person then
actually if I'm already a nice person I
want to improve how do I improve that
how do you improve it yeah definitely
being even more nicer than what you are
now okay there's ways around working on
that as well
I think it's the way you're wearing it
maybe maybe but I mean that there but
there is more to it you know I mean you
can't just be oh okay I like this person
because their personality is great and
I'm agreeing with you yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I get it I feel like because
you were saying there was something else
that you know women don't show or women
what I've picked personality on purpose
because that's what appeals to me as a
person like I don't care how pretty you
are I don't care what you have I don't
care that's what okay like it's like
kindness nurturing yeah
I prefer to feel like warmed and and
have that feeling you know what I mean
right but when you're worrying about
whether you're glamor and all this [__]
like I can't give a [__] what percent
what percent of women are really like
learning how like let's just say cook
because that like that's something that
men tend to like oh yeah yeah
I think what percent of women are saying
you know what I'm gonna really learn how
to like cooking
to spend time with married couples to
see what that girl's doing right I think
every girl can be submissive to the
right guy I think a girl who could learn
to cook if she's in love with the guy
yeah
I agree with you yeah no I think there's
some that are too far gone but yeah some
of C4 come but if it goes without really
feeding the guy she'll be submissual
lunch you want to do stuff for him like
cook yeah you know do like his laundry
no and I hear this all the time from
girls it's like I gave him everything I
did too much I did so much but it's kind
of sad because it's like a lot of times
when that happens like they'll make them
out of the future pay for the mistakes
of their past so it's like like he like
oh I gave everything to him so I can't
give everything to the next guy I was
like well what did he do
that tends to happen in a lot of
relationships with people that the girls
being heartbroken from previous and they
choose to bring that same energy into
the new one and then not realize they're
Truman from the loss instead of learning
from it yeah letting it go yeah okay but
again this is just in society these days
people
don't get me wrong but I fall in certain
situations you can heal alone and life
can teach you certain things you know
what I'm saying that that's what I'm
saying and it comes back to like when he
was talking about emotions yeah like
I've been like I'll be I'll put it out
there like I've been a person yeah all
my life like man's just been angry for
what reason I don't know Matt because my
dad were around might be because how
things were going back in the day or how
I grew up whatever I was in but I
realized being not not saying I should
just be upset and be crying all the time
but when I did cry
from being the angry person I was it
released so much negative it made me
feel more like raw yeah I can breathe
you know what I'm saying and that's why
I said men don't cry but they don't
realize how much is boiling up inside
but you leveled up though after that
anything you learned from those
situations that's the problem though and
I know that's what I know why like I
understand myself you know I mean you've
got to know yourself yeah that bush
knows himself to see how where he's
coming from what he's talking about he's
in a different realm do you get me but I
get it because over the years you've had
to teach yourself these things it's Yes
Man woke up
mistakes
and it's done but don't you think it's
better if men Express their emotions to
other men as opposed to that's what I'm
trying to say yeah like I just don't
think women are built from that yeah
picking a specific person I was just
saying in general in life yeah if you
don't get upset and don't let it out
You're Gonna Keep It In what I'm
bottling up turns into anger sometimes
yeah well I'm not saying never cry but
it's just you know it's like when we
think of our strong like the strongest
most masculine men like the archetypes
like like a Rocky Balboa I've actually
never seen the movie but I I know he's
like a masculine Arc it was he crying in
the movie we've been we've been this is
what he's done so the programming is
it's about like it's it's there to make
you think that oh if he does that it
means he's weak but we will have
emotions we have feelings I mean and
there's going to be a time in life where
we're all going to shed a terrible to or
talk about I think society's gone the
other way though I think Society is like
encouraging men to cry more and be more
emotional well no not what I'm seeing no
yeah they're trying to push it they are
yeah
way too much I think it's probably what
I'm what I'm seeing and that's why
that's why you know there's a whole
agenda of men being soft and like way
too soft and not having the work ethic
that a guy had like 20 30 years ago I
know I can speak to my uncles and then
they'll tell me like oh like people's
generation are lazy like they haven't
got no work no drive like you can't even
do this basic job you know what I'm
saying
yeah yeah I mean it's media it is it's
always going to come back to social
media yeah I mean because that is what
it is but I personally see the use
they're not violin because they're
always on crack but it just might be
just the circle of what I see you know I
mean I don't know I don't look into the
statistics and the numbers they turn the
upset into anger is that what you're
saying yeah I see more violence yeah
yeah I see more people crying because
the kids are dead then man balling and
being more emotional and feminine which
is it so I don't I don't know maybe the
area I grew up in or where I'm in is why
I'm seeing these things because I really
don't know the research side of it's
gone feminine I haven't clocked that yet
I don't think it's gone way too fast
even the emotions of getting angry
infectious and it's still emotions you
know and it is disproportionate and it's
not that cool for then it's still it's
still emotions and whether you're crying
the internal whether you're screaming
with happiness and joy yes and it's
still emotions and it's stack all I'm
saying is just kind of have it in a
balance and ability to manage the
situation yeah and over years that's
what I had to do yes and I was keeping I
always said that when I went and done
anger management when I was at school I
realized that right why am I always
angry yeah well I might want to be angry
and I'm angry at me but it's just I was
always I can always snap because I was a
loose screw like that I just didn't want
to piss me off my answer years have gone
on and I've grown up to deal with my
emotions so like if something upsets me
I'll go into a room quietly and have my
my deal with my [__] but then I'll come
back because who you saw but you learned
from that lesson
a lot of guys get into a deep hole they
don't learn from them no you know what
I'm saying to the crying and it's like
they get worse and they're crying it
worse and if it lives over and they
think you know what yeah that's
depression
the therapist people then but what I
will say from my point of view how I
dealt with that situation because I was
always on a Vex team
um The Crying helped me in a way where
it made me understand that like what I'm
crying about and why I'm crying and who
I cry around do you get me in the house
cry around know any person but like I'm
crying around my circle and crying with
people who love me
yeah see what I'm saying so I've learned
a way of how to deal with it instead of
just keeping it all bowled up because I
can clutch Road and if that's bored that
blood is Peak yeah
you've learned to control your emotions
you've experience
and I hear what you've been saying when
you're saying the crying too much can't
make can look a bit like Michael's
saying it's a weekly now I don't think
it's strong but that's because that
Brothers let it get on tops to
understand there's a level of bar linen
who you're crying around and what how
you're carrying yourself do I mean you
can cry and look you on the floor
I'm very important you got crime on
certain people that you know that love
you that's going to be have your best
interests
yeah
they're gonna look at that and think oh
yeah they're used to manipulate you so
someone submitted a question for the
guys
um if a random woman accused your dad of
grape would he be okay
mine would definitely
that's a wild one wild wild wild
question to ask me because do you mean
would he be okay with accusation yeah no
like would he be mentally okay I don't
know why he asked that I don't know it's
a good question but again it's again
controlling the emotion again if you
again it comes to knowing yourself if
you know yourself I can speak for my dad
he's very
sitting away yeah and he knows if again
if he knows he hasn't raped someone yes
he's gonna be okay great great yeah
the words
you guys answer with your dad oh yeah I
think I think it'll be a casual I think
because if my dad's traditional so I
think it's like like traditional beliefs
core values or strong-minded you know I
let some any random person what they're
going to say affect you so I think it'll
be different if there's someone like you
know maybe mid-30s or younger and that
would be different
okay
um I'm gonna Read Super chats really
quick I think we might have got through
all of them
uh
um
okay big boy
um because of guys like this women think
that they are the best even five
straight simps why do you bring these
type of guys on Pearl come on sorry
um Lawrence block
um the three worst isms um communism
racism and feminism
um Johnny Yelp
um
bro I can't remember I think I read that
one already Let me refresh it real quick
okay
guys also make sure you sign up for
our Google list for our meetups oh okay
there's one more mayor interracial
relationship sex dating and marriage
says Men Express their emotions through
acts of aggression Sports video games
martial arts romance and sex violence
can be the result of a loss of emotional
control a man has due to disrespect
um Luke reckon let me be emotional Pearl
nice restyling I love your dress own
choice or Maggie
um someone else picked that you guys
already know someone else picked it
um
and then there's another one from Luca
they're telling me
so what I missed I don't think so
okay
um okay so it's getting a little late so
I think we're gonna close out the show
okay cool um but you guys can say any
final thoughts so you have thank you
guys so much for coming no thanks for
having us man thank you
you got me
um Final Cut final words I think what
that guy said about Simpsons is a crap
none of us have a college man to be a
Sim I think he's just chatting
rubbishment
they just like to yes
but I personally what what what what
bugs me here in the conversation is
about the emotional thing is because
like but I'm telling you like if there's
not enough man out there expressing
herself not telling my ball but I'm
saying if it's bottling up and you know
there's that you need that time away to
to take that that time out and refresh
and restart reset do you understand do
it you get me don't feel like you can't
don't make your don't let no one judge
you because you cried or you you you
don't have your emotions in that way
just don't let it get out of control
don't let it get above you in it that's
what I'm saying like personally like I
said myself I've had to manage my anger
my anger side of things from a young you
understand because maybe it might have
been my dad were around you get me or
maybe it weren't certain person always
dare to see to my situations when it was
going on when I was a youth man do you
get me but I've had to learn and manage
that myself and all I would say to
everyone else out there as a guy as for
men don't feel ashamed to actually just
express your feelings because I don't
think women will look at you any weaker
than or stronger because you cried to
understand that the majority will
probably say they don't want a alpha man
who's not going to show their their
feelings they want a man who's going to
open up and and show that side but know
when to and know how to carry yourself
when you're doing that do you understand
don't do it on a and then she's thinking
I'm gonna get away with him but do you
see where I'm coming from you might be
saying it in a mad way because my
whereas playing stuff is a bit all over
no you said it right I think you said it
right I I see what you're saying what
I'll say is I think things people I
think as a guy going through certain uh
traumas and stuff is necessary for the
if the guy's able to overcome it as part
of his growth and I feel like you've
gone through certain things and you're
able to deal with it and you've ever to
build your character and I feel as
necessary as a man to go through certain
things and trans tribulations to build
their character but I'll say it's
perfectly fine to cry and let your
emotions but I will say also to remember
okay cool to the end of the world and
okay you quite a little emotions go now
it's time to Let's level up let's
improve let's let's build you know what
I'm saying I think a lot of guys
um May foreign
[Music]
times create strong man self-development
and I think the problem is like like
honestly we haven't had enough hardships
where like we're so weak as a society
like that we think today's hardships are
like actually hard when they're not it's
like the men the men of yesterday used
to have to go to war and they used to
have to like they would get drafted and
go to war that was their hard time and
now it's like we have more mental issues
with mental issues in the old days used
to be trauma like real trauma not just
your ex-boyfriend cheated on you trauma
but like real trauma like like from war
but now it's like what is our trauma
yeah you said a good point in there as
well when you said you've got to go
through the [__] before you end up
becoming stronger in it so yeah but but
I think trauma like I think hard times
are different for men and for women like
I think women it doesn't like it makes
us worse but I think men it makes them
better yeah empowers money yeah like men
can come out of something and become a
stronger man or if a woman comes through
something like like the women with the
most like I think a lot of times guys
that have the most effed up past can
come out okay like and they can come out
like stronger and better but like what
does a girl come out with like Daddy
Issues yeah it's I just don't think it's
the same and not not to say you know
there's still a lot of problems with
like messed up past them both ways but I
just think men are better able to handle
the problems of the world and I actually
spoke to a hormone doctor about this
um like this guy I interview people a
lot so I just learn all these
interesting facts right and this guy was
telling me how women and men's hormones
react differently to stress so men's
like hormones it increases their
testosterone where women I can't
remember what how it messes us up I
forgot what he told me but in some way
like it makes us worse and we like don't
handle stress the same wow
[Music]
anything to say no I'm just taking in
the knowledge yeah there's you know it's
crazy because it's like there's things
that are like honestly like tails the
old like as old as time that it's just
like basic common sense and it like you
don't really need to study to like tell
you that men and women handle stress
differently like there's a reason men
went to war and there's a reason that
women stayed home with the kids you
don't really need to study to tell you
that kids are better with two parents in
the home like there's things that like
genuinely I don't even think you really
you just need common sense to figure out
but it's like Society is trying to
switch it on us but for what that's
right control
it makes them more money exactly money
control Power and the day well that's
what that's what I'll finish off if I
say a lot it's all right we all go
through stresses we'll go through hard
times it's about overcoming these hard
times and I will say also for guys oh
stop watching other people stop
dinosaurs music comparing a lot of
people and because it makes you feel a
type of way it makes you feel like
you're less of a man if someone else is
doing better and everyone everyone goes
to different stages in life so if you're
going through stresses but I'll say work
on yourself work on your mental health
and you can control it as well because a
lot of guys think they can't improve you
know their mental health because they
think oh society makes them feel like
they're hopeless and they're doing but
you can if you work out you
you know you can control what you can
control like the eating side of things
the training side of things you do
yourself the event where you can come
overcome it that's all I'll say make
sure you invested in your uh mental
health and try and control what you can
control because sometimes you can't
control other things but you can control
you know you know the eat inside Health
side you know your mind what you consume
you know what you read and all that
stuff as well so I'll say it to a man to
try and pound yourself yeah therefore
I'm done that's good yeah it's
interesting you just said that it would
maybe think about when you're saying
about war men going to war and women not
going to war and I just walk against
this emotional making erratic decisions
yes and by your emotions women are a bit
more logical and incense Etc that that I
just brought that randomly but anyway my
final thoughts would be
um
main ones love yourself I don't we've
said that enough on this channel today
you already love yourself understand
yourself really know yourself yes I'm
being lying and in tune with yourself
and once you kind of cover that basis in
um obviously you've got to love yourself
to love other people and once you love
yourself to a higher level
is that do unto others as you have them
do unto you yourself basically and again
I think that's a kind of cure for a lot
of the problems we've been talking about
the intent I mean it's a very long shot
but this would be in my mind the way
that we can go around curing it so
loving yourself when you do really love
yourself then you're going to treat
other people with respect because that's
how you want them to treat you
no that's nice
um yeah social media is a facade and
just focus on self-development don't
worry about anyone else half the time
it's not real it's not real we've
probably seen it all with our own eyes
it's not real yeah quick question before
we end do you feel like that mentality
has helped you be in a relationship for
so long because it's really rare for
girls your age
[Music]
um to be honest I don't know I feel like
I've never really thought social media
was real anyway so I feel like I've had
that mindset from the beginning so it
could be but I wouldn't know because
I've never really thought like that so
I've never thought that yeah
okay guys um thank you all for coming
this is a fun panel
um make sure you guys like the video on
your way out that is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams also guys we have um two
clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily make sure you go subscribe
to both and sign up for uh my fourth
membership tier to get a one-on-one call
with me once a month also guys follow my
Instagram just pearly things one make
sure you go subscribe to wife school
um where we learn traditional skills in
a modern world
um also guys
um make sure you go follow
um all three of our talents go follow
amiri's Channel Auntie Jenny's Channel
and um King Rich's Channel and we are
looking for more talents to sign so if
you got a pitch for a YouTube channel
idea you know send it my way we do
everything from production to editing
where you just sit down and talk so yeah
it's a really good deal um follow me on
Instagram like the video on your way out
and I will talk to you guys next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things you YouTube channel and welcome
to the pregame
[Applause]
I actually agree with you I think they
do do it for the men but it's like
sexual tension it's not relationship
attention so you can kind of do a cheat
code you can go get a BBL get a nice
body and you do get more attention from
men than if you're flat right but here's
the thing though no no but but listen
though if it goes so deeper though
because I know what you're talking about
and he has a great body yeah so you got
to think about how far down deep that
she is within watching the Instagram
models within watching The Cosmopolitan
magazines
bat her great body doesn't look good to
a man but you think that men have higher
standards for women not that the men
have the higher standards they have to
live up to just to clarify I think men
have highest and just for women for
women so like the women have higher
beauty standards to me yes and that's
what's making women feel like they need
to comply with these standards who's
pickier men or women men women are more
complacent than men
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept all women are very like if
they're they've got a certain standard
they're more rigid than women something
men are pickier than women 100
definitely but they will not marry it
they will not settle down with somebody
with a focal lips the eyebrows and if
they do it ain't gonna last so I I done
an only fan I thought it wasn't like
vagina boobs it was lingerie yeah builds
right whatever I'd done it and when I
finished it I felt very degraded I felt
very like why did I actually do that now
I know there's girls out there who do
that they don't feel that way that is
perfectly fine you do you you feel the
way you feel but me personally like like
in the future how like when I have kids
and all in the future and if my kids
found out about that they'll probably
get bullied in school there are people
like oh your mom doing this your mom
doing that and your man as well he's not
going to if you don't respect yourself
and you're selling your body online I
can't speak for everyone I can just
speak for myself if you're selling your
body online like that there's not a
there's not a high respect for yourself
foreign